Boom. Here we go. Yeah, buddy. Good
to see you. Great. Good to be here.
We were talking before the podcast about,
uh,
people who get mad when I have you on.
Like as if you're some sort of a monster.
You're a mean person. Like I didn't
need her to say you're a New York Jew,
you're snarky.
You say funny things,
but this idea that you're a Nazi or
something like people have gotten soap.
This is this ice breaker. Hey, by the
way, why do people think you're nuts?
Someone sent me,
I don't read comments on Twitter,
but someone sent me something like,
you having this guy on today and I'm like,
that is so hilarious. I go, this guy
is, yeah, there's some shit you say.
I don't agree with. Sure. You're very
reasonable and very intelligent. Yeah.
The last chapter of the book A's me
arguing with the Nazi conversation folks.
It's not bad. It's not bad.
I talk that I, well, it's,
it's kind of for them a religious
thing, right? If someone is a sinner,
you can't acknowledge that they
have to be outside of the fort.
That's a good way to look at it. That is
what it is. You know what's interesting?
It's,
I know these people don't mean to do this.
This is not their plan, but if you
wanted to keep Donald Trump in office,
the w the way the people that oppose
Donald Trump are behaving is the perfect
way to keep them in office.
If you tell high schoolers if you smoke,
you're parents are going to get upset
and the teacher didn't get upset.
That's the biggest question. Right?
Right. Yeah. So you tell these kids,
Hey, if you go to these
websites and read these books,
then your parents and the establishment
and the teachers are all gonna be afraid
of you. Well, sign me up. I
mean, it's as simple as that.
It's the same exact psychology and they're
driving people to the fringe they are.
And the the D platforming
things fascinating.
Because the way this stuff works folks,
is when people get DDI platform.
The first people that will get deep
platform are people that you agree with
getting d platformed. People
like, you know, I'll go real Nazi.
Like someone who's a, an
avowed white supremacy, like
yeah, d platform, that guy,
and that's a little slippery because then
it's like this guy's a suspected Nazi,
or this guy is friends with a Nazi, or
this guy hadn't rights. He on his show,
this guy had a white
supremacists onto this show.
This guy had a guy who thinks it's okay
to be white on his show and then it gets,
it gets more,
as it gets more and more progressive,
it gets more and more preposterous,
but it really is great.
It's once you accept one grade,
then you drop below in a little bit more
preposterous and then that's acceptable
and then a little bit more and
then that becomes accepted.
And it's a double standard between people
who are Orthodox and people who are
unorthodox. Barbara Walters sat down
with Castro. She sat down with Kadafi,
who's killed how many
people? Yeah, that's fine.
You could sit down with the
murderers dictator if you're Kadafi.
If you sit down with someone on a
podcast with someone who has all point of
views, that is somehow different.
Well, it's a new thing, right?
Platforming and d platforming and you put
putting this guy on your platform like
all this, this, this kind of communication
is very new. I just didn't exist.
No one was saying that to Mike
Wallace. No, no one's saying that.
As you're saying to Barbara Walters,
that was my argument to the Damien's data
and society lady. I said, Jesus, I said,
Barbara Walters interviewed Fidel Castro.
Does that make her a communist?
Like all right, I interviewed Milo. Am
I a gay conservative provocateur now?
I don't think so. You need to go to a
doctor for sure. I mean, what, what, what,
what they, what they're trying
to do is thanks to social media.
They no longer have a monopoly and I
don't mean they have just been like
Orthodox thought isn't he left wing and
right wing Orthodox thought no longer
has a monopoly on the microphone.
And that's very dangerous if you want
to basically set the boundaries of what
acceptable discourse is. Same thing with,
forget politics. Look up music, right?
If you want to say these are the co
you shouldn't have lyrics like this.
People shouldn't dance like this. They
shouldn't, you know, dress a certain way.
This is what they would like.
I mean back in the nineties you remember
they'd had the warning labels on cds
and says this has explicit lyrics and
that way Walmart could with clean hands
say we're not being involved.
Politics, we're following their rules.
So that's what this data was society
ladies trying to do. It's like, okay,
I'm giving you target
whatever company and excuse,
these are the people you don't need to
deal with. And then they could say, well,
it's not up to us. We're looking at this
from an external point of view. Well,
and also my perspective on it is that
there's certain subjects that I think that
we can all agree we need to cover and we
need to deal with in terms of laws and
in terms of the way the government is run.
But a lot of these
disagreements aren't on that.
A lot of these disagreements seem to be
just on political ideologies and like
liberal versus conservative ideologies.
And people think differently.
They have different styles
of behavior and thinking.
This is why like if you had a station
that played hip hop and all of a sudden
you just got a bunch of Aerosmith
songs playing, he'd be like,
what the fuck is this?
This is not what I want.
Get this off the station except
for walk this way. That's good.
Well the one with run DMC,
that was one exception,
but that that's sort of how a lot of
people seem to be approaching conservative
versus progressive thinking is it's
like once you have this mindset,
you don't want to hear other opinions as
if they're going to influence you or if
you don't like the way they sound,
you don't like what they're doing and
you want to get them off the channel.
And this is what it seems
like is happening with social
media platforms, right?
Is that the social media platforms
are like, we're a country station.
We don't play heavy metal.
Get that shit off our network.
Like we are a progressive network.
We don't play conservative.
Get that stuff off. Well if they had
said that we're progressive in that way,
it's like a server that would be honest
and fair, but they, the claim is no,
we are banning people who
are doing x, Y and Z. Yeah.
And you know for people that are like,
oh my God,
they're talking about this
again, two fuckers, listen,
this is really important shit.
This is going to decide how we,
this is, this didn't exist
before. Okay. And now it does.
Now we have this unbelievable
ability to communicate and I'm enjoying
it right now talking to you. Right?
We're all enjoying it if you're tweeting
about this or writing comments about
this,
but it's,
if this really branches off into a one
side get to do it and one side doesn't,
we're going to have a fucking
tremendous problem in this country.
If you think that this problem
that we have right now and it's,
it's just starting to be an issue
over the last couple of years.
If you think that this is what this could
escalate, it's like a serious conflict,
which I mean almost like it's,
it's absolutely reasonable to think that
violence could come out of this. Well,
the Trump presidency was
the escalation before Trump.
It was okay [inaudible] fake news with
this left idea that like this, you know,
this new sites of putting out lies your,
if your point of view is different
to mine, it's not just wrong.
It's illegitimate. Right? And a lot of
people in that voting booth and said,
you want an illegitimacy?
Okay,
I'm voting for Donald Trump for president
and now he's in the White House.
So for you to say that, if people
to say that these ideas, you know,
are evil and shouldn't be discussed,
those are separate concepts.
Cause even if you think they're evil,
if from your point of view,
it's in the White House,
are you going to pretend this isn't the
most powerful man in the world? It's,
there's a big contradiction there,
but one of the things progressivism offers
many people is this idea of truth and
certainty.
Knowing you're one of the good guys and
knowing you're in the majority and when
you find that that is not always true.
I think that caused some cognitive stress,
you know? No, I would
absolutely agree with that.
I just think there's a real problem
that's happening now with some of the
accounts that I'm seeing. Getting
banned without reason, without reason,
for things that are like parody accounts.
Carpay docked them.
So I interrupt you.
He's the one who made this great meme
during the state of the Union where he,
ted,
president Trump and all the,
he said footage from the state of the
Union of the Democrats looking pissed and
he put it over the song. Everybody
hurts, right? There's two minute video.
It's a joke. It's fun, right?
You could see on second life,
you don't have to be Republican or
Democrats to laugh at Saraf pluses.
They got a copyright strike cause it's
like you don't have the right to use the
music. Trump had retweeted
it. He put out another one,
he just got suspended for a week. He did
the video from my book. So they don't,
here's the thing, if someone is a name,
you can say, hey, delete this tweet.
It violates our guidelines,
right? You give them warnings,
you could call their manager. They don't
do that. You're just vanished overnight.
And there's something very Soviet about
this because when they vanish you,
your entire archives get managed
to, and it's like, wait a minute,
this person's bad and dangerous.
Don't you want to show other people
as an example of what to avoid?
Like this will get you banned so you
can modify your behavior accordingly.
But what they want,
apparently it looks like what they want
is for everyone to be self censoring and
to be afraid. And that way it's like, uh,
instead of saying we're since, sure. Yes.
It's like you made that
decision on your own. Well,
I know Trump has been talking about this
now because it affects so many people
that are supporters. Right. And he's, um,
been discussing that the idea that
these people need to abide by the first
amendment and then there's your argument
will either they're a private company,
they can put on whatever
they want and they
can decide whatever they want or they're
protected by the first amendment.
You know, I had Tulsa Gabber don the
other day. She was running her love her.
I love her too. And she's running. I asked
her, do my Shushu wouldn't reply. Really?
Yeah. Why? I don't know. She
didn't reply. I don't know.
Having that say on compound media, Guest
Digital, Oh, you're already has digital.
That's even more disgusting. And
compound media. That's the problem.
And all that good ways. It all the
good ways. Listen, I love Lewis.
I love all those guys are savages
lose. She's probably like, oh fuck.
I forgot I'm savage Jason. Like I'll
have those guys. You know what I mean?
I have officially gotten permission
that the room we all recording.
It's called the gas chamber.
Oh, Jesus. Yeah. You could
say that. I could say that.
Yeah. You're alone. Yeah. Where
you guys put that privilege.
Yeah. That's privilege.
Do Frivolous. Yeah. Yeah. Um, maybe
she will, um, I'll, I'll look,
tell her about it.
But she was on her and I are besties,
tele slash two by the time
I really do respect the shit out of her.
I really do. Um, you know, I'd
love to call her madam president.
I think that'd be dope. She's smart, man.
She's, she's, she's so measured. I mean,
she doesn't have all the answers.
And some of the things that she says
are things that you say, you know,
I'm not sure we're going to, we're going
to have to work to create more jobs.
Like those kinds of, that kind of talk.
It's like politician talk and I go, okay,
well what would that mean? And we'll
have to figure that out. And I,
I think she's sincere, but these
answers, you know, don't really exist.
Like how to fix the inner cities.
Like how to like,
these are the like some that some of
the big issues that you discussed.
We talked about, um, like
horrible neighborhoods that
have always been harmed,
right? Like, how was this?
Like we're going to fucking
Afghanistan trying to fix their, yeah.
And we're not trying to fix Chicago, the
south side Chicago. What's happening now?
Why? Why are so many people getting shot?
How come we can't fix it? It's funny.
Back in the day they had something called
slum clearance and the idea was if you
tear down these old buildings
and build new buildings,
somehow the crime's going to go away. And
this was a big nation. It's just like,
yeah, it's the buildings
fall fucking content houses,
they have decades and decades of
crack and bullets flying through them.
That's so crazy.
But she's great because she,
my biggest issue is anti war.
Yes.
At anyone for me whose first priority
isn't let's stop killing people.
Yeah. That I'm a fan of. Yeah.
And she's also a veteran.
Yeah. 16 years. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm a big fan. Um, but
you know, I think, um,
this country needs more, you know,
we need a, we need real plans.
We need like someone, we just, the
way we engineer software systems,
um, you know, search engines,
operating systems for cell phones,
they should engineers society.
I mean we should really be looking
at it in terms of the potential for
prosperity opportunity, all these
different things that we don't cover.
We just sort of leave so much
up to chance because we buy the,
the bullshit that like,
I mean,
I think we all know at this point then
not everyone's on an even playing field,
which is not, but we don't think
a lot of people know that. Well,
they're fucking crazy. And that's the
problem. Yeah. Yes, they're fucking,
if you don't think
that being born in a crime
or in a neighborhood with
violence all around you and
being exposed at an early age fucks
your head up. I don't even mean that.
I think the fact that said, admit that
a lot of people aren't hardworking.
Oh yeah,
there's that too.
And I like to say that out there as
shocking to many people. It's like, yeah,
some people are bad.
Some people think that just because they
show up at work and they don't want to,
that they're working hard. Right.
It's hard for them. You fucking,
you just go lucky or you do the,
you know what I read,
that was one of the more hilarious
things that I've ever heard of crazy
progressive person. Right.
If you are successful,
it is because someone else got
fucked over. That's so disturbing.
But it's such a crazy way to
look at it. It's like, okay,
somewhere down the chain already,
if you have an iPhone,
someone got fucked over that
logic, right? No, no, no,
no.
The logic is someone had to work as a
slave and Foxconn to make these fucking
iPhones for like 15 cents a week
or whatever they make over there.
But if it wasn't making 15 cents a week,
that slave would be dead.
That's what they're saying.
It's squirrely. Right. Cause,
but yeah, but is that okay?
Like when they go to third world countries
and set up these sweatshops and uh,
like I knew someone who had one and
they were like doing fucking mental
gymnastics to try to justify.
And I was like, wait a minute,
how much he paid his
people and they were like,
they were going to starve to
death if it wasn't for us. Mike,
are you sure they were there?
Right? They were there.
They probably been there for thousands
of years. Like where'd you go?
Like Guatemala, where was it? Argentina?
Like where are you said I'll
give you two examples that are,
maybe I can't speak to specific
second world examples. North Korea,
which has obviously my beat. Yeah,
that's your beat. So there is a, um,
a zone between north and South Korea where
they work together. DMZ, motherfucker.
No, but it's like this enrichment zone.
And in your case all work together, right?
So the North Korean has worked at the
South Korea has kind of put it together.
Oh. And the government takes
like 95% of your money.
And also North Koreans who work in Russia
in logging camps where the government
takes like 95% of your money.
They're slaves. They're 100% slaves.
But they're beating down their doors to
work in these locations because they're
providing for their family and they're
still wealthier than the alternative. Now,
this is a very extreme situation.
This isn't like, I don't know,
third world what country your,
your friend has a sweatshop in.
But there are circumstances where a lot
of people on the left and on the right
don't understand often that
politics and economics is about,
often you have two bad choices. Like
what is the alternative? It's like,
what do you like? For example,
you're going to put forth the law.
What are you going to do about people
who are going to look at this law?
Not In good faith. Like there was that
guy was named zoomies Judy who said,
I'm trans and he just made a
video break. Newbies. Zov Yeah,
he just broke the woman's dead referees
like, Oh man, here we go. By the way,
they took those, uh,
records away from that.
An Australian woman that you see guy there
was Australia, right? Wasn't the world.
The power lifting woman's world records.
She broke like three of them.
So it's not even about trans
stuff. It's like, what do you do
with any law when someone is
going to act in bad faith?
And if you can't account for that,
you're not being a responsible
with your proposal. Yeah.
This isn't even a law though. We're
talking about with the Trans Athletes.
It's just,
it's loopholes.
So some weird people don't want to be
seen as trans phobic in today's climate.
So that allowing preposterous things.
What was that like for you?
And you were talking,
I remember when you're talking to Adam
on this show that got pretty heated.
Oh yeah. Adam ruins everything.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, it didn't
get heated. We just, I mean,
I never got upset. We,
we've absolutely disagreed,
but he had some crazy notions about
competition that didn't make any sense
either.
Like that somehow or another,
the sports are designed
to favor men. What? Yeah.
It didn't make any sense. It was a lot
of it was progressive rehashing. Okay.
In my opinion,
I think it sounded good to him,
but I don't know how much
actual thought is put into it.
What's actually interesting is like in
his show he's well researched and no
one's opposing these,
this data that he's putting out.
So he gets to say these things is one
of the problems with like writing a blog
or making a video about
something where no one goes.
Actually that's not really true.
This is why that's not true.
Let me explain and this is why
you're wrong. And now continue.
See when you could just go on
these long unchecked rants.
That's where you get like flat earth
believers. That's what that shit from.
Cause they watch those videos and they go,
oh this makes sense.
But this is why it's so important that
unorthodox voices don't get the platforms.
Because even if that person is proposed
putting for things that are completely
full of shit,
they're criticism and their perspective,
they might have some truth in it.
And at the very least,
like when I was at Charlottesville and
I talked to these people by talking to
them, it makes me think through why do I
believe what I believe? Why is my truth,
the actual truth? And I'm going
to be challenged on my views.
And I'm going to have a better
grounding for them as opposed to,
like you're saying,
if I'm sitting here just
giving a monologue and no
one ever calls me out on my
bullshit. Yeah. I think
I see what you're saying.
And I think what they think is you
have to silence these bad voices.
Like the Anti vaccs movement. That's a
big one right now. People are saying,
you've got to silence NTP. So they're
taking an anti vaccs videos down there,
taking into vax pages down.
You know,
I don't know how much they actually
know about the science, you know,
I don't,
I mean,
vaccines are incredible for health in
terms of what they've done to protect us
from diseases. They've stopped
smallpox, they've stopped polio.
And when you see these
outbreaks of measles,
that is a direct result of people
not getting vaccinated. You know?
Does that mean that no one's ever been
hurt by vaccines? No. No, it doesn't, man.
There's a vaccine court. People been
injured. People have died. That's a fact.
But that's, I think, just a part of
medical procedures and human beings. Men,
a lot of kids die every year from
circumcision. Yeah. They get infections.
They lose their penises. Yeah.
Yeah. It's like very common,
like way more common in terms of like
the numbers per year than you would ever
want to hear. Oh God. Okay. People
die from things. They get infections.
People get, have allergic
reactions to certain chemicals.
Then the problem is now those vaxxers
can say we're being covered up now.
They're honest. It's the truth. They are
being covered or being covered up. Yeah.
So it's a very, I would think it
problem is who's right and who's wrong.
Like if you're a person and you
have a child and you terrified,
can you go to these websites
and like, oh my God, um,
I don't want my kid to get autism.
Like what they're saying that vaccines
cause autism. I'm not vaccinating my kids.
I'm not going to take the chance.
And that's where a lot of it comes in.
If you watch those videos and you watch
a video that's not done by a scientist,
that's not up to date on what
we know about what causes,
like I had Peter Hotez on who's um,
very knowledgeable about vaccines and
very knowledgeable about diseases in
general and he was describing the,
the what they think the
causes of autism are.
That how it takes place in the womb and
how what's most likely happening is it's
just expressing itself at the same time
that the kids getting vaccinated and
you're correlating the
two things together.
Well there's also the movement of
not regarding autism as a problem or,
or door a Cota, you know,
children of deaf adults, you know,
you have these parents whose kids are
deaf and they refuse to get them cochlear
implants to give them the ability to
hear cause they think that's losing deaf
culture. Now to me, you never heard
this? No. This is a thing. Yeah.
For me,
everything is a thing because you can
see it when you think about it for a few
seconds,
you can understand where they're coming
from because you're going to be like,
well, you're saying I'm bad
because I'm deaf. I know it's like,
but then you hear people that are like
Trans Disabled. Do you know what that is?
Whether they cut their hand off because
they feel like they're supposed to have
no hand, no. Oh yes. Oh yeah. See
these things. This is what I'm saying.
Like they're all,
I'm lumping them all together because
what they are is all of them are these
weird variables when it comes to human
behavior and thinking and patterns and
biology.
Oh,
he's weird variables where you get so
many numbers and if you have all these
people, 300 whatever million
we have in this country,
you're going to have a few thousand
of almost every fucking variable,
every weird variable. Good
Lord I lord. Yeah. I'll,
I know is the politics
that the health stuff,
I don't even want to wait into that too.
That was why I was, there was an old,
a website that I was going to, um,
what was that body modification?
Extreme [inaudible] that guy
BME, he died the Lizard Guy? No,
the cat guy.
His name was Shannon Shannon,
I think Shannon laureate
is how you say his name,
but B m e x body modification extreme was
the website. Um, he and I became like a,
uh, pen pen pals going back.
Like he sent me some stuff on,
I wrote something once
about body modification.
Like what kind of weird shit people
do it. And he's like, hey man,
if you ever have any questions, feel
free to ask me. This is my website.
He sent me a to his wet cause it was
like one of those six he had to pay for a
membership and I was like, Holy Shit,
you go to this website and it's just,
it was just, this was in
the 90s. Okay. And the,
the most freakish,
weirdest fucking body modifications.
And there's a whole culture behind it.
People putting horns on their heads
and doing weird shit to their skin,
making them sold out and tattoo
in their whole face. Melissa,
she had magnets implanted on her fingers.
I don't know why.
We never know what I would, I think the
magnet, well you have to pick things up.
You don't want to close your hand. Fuck
is wrong with the frog magnets. Well,
people think that magnet like where
magnets is a wristband supposed to be good
for you cares autism, but you
get the vaccine magnet. You know,
it sounds stupid,
but they use magnetic therapy for veterans
that have PTSD and CTE because um,
there's areas of the brain
that can actually stimulate
with these very powerful
magnets.
A Cat Zingano UFC fighter.
She went down there when she was having
some serious repercussions from her
fight with Amanda Nunez.
She got really battered badly in the
first round and her hormones are out of
whack for months afterwards.
She was all fucked up.
Her Cortisol levels were all fucked up
and finally she went and got some milk.
Sparring was off her time. And these
options are, I just have to rush people.
I didn't have any sense of timing.
Oh yeah.
She was on real problems with
their brain and they fixed it.
They fixed it with magnets. These,
these electromagnetic pulse on,
I'm just saying words
that I don't understand.
So if you're a scientist and
you're like, well, shut the fuck.
Are you saying this side? Just tweeting
at you? Feverously call. Listen,
angry scientist come with you. I'm, I'm,
I'm retarded. Listen, they throw these,
these,
these waves at the brain and somehow
know that these electromagnetic waves
stimulate areas of the mind
and it actually forces brain
cells to grow in forces
neural connections. It's
really interesting stuff.
Cats Ganos played it pretty,
pretty, pretty in depth,
but it really helped her.
So it's weird that a
magnet would work for that,
but those are like really strong ones.
Okay. The little ones around your wrists.
But it might, I mean, I don't
know the fuck do I know? Yeah.
I'm not spending that 24 99
in that fucking bracelet,
but it's kind of an English
guy that's selling it.
That's how you know it's
legit and it comes with a
mop, comes with a free shammy.
Remember the sham? Wow Guy. He's dead,
isn't he? Yeah. Didn't you guys Israeli?
You get bit by a hooker.
Yeah. What's the other one?
Who got the oxyclean guys dead?
Billy. Whatever. Shamwows alive. Yeah.
Billy was tooting up. Yeah.
Is that what it was? Yeah.
He had a lot of coconut system
apparently. Oh, Playtech.
Right. Well listen, I got that oxy
money that clean your sinuses up.
Do you want to fucking party?
Who's probably had a yellow
Lamborghini Dick Implant. Just kidding.
I made that part up.
I'm sure he was a great guy.
Wasn't in the middle of
doing a television show.
They were doing a television show
about him. Uh, yeah, he was, well,
he had the pitchman.
It was like a sitcom or something.
It was like a reality show.
Reality type show.
They're following them around
doing pitches and stuff.
There's an art to that
shit. Those guys, he's,
he got me to realize
shark tank before them.
I think they were helping people do stuff
sorta like kitchen nightmares. Yeah.
I'm friends with the son.
The shark tanks on the no sham.
Well really made friends with Billy May
son. Yeah, I went to school with, Oh,
I'm sorry. I said all this. What's
his son's name was just joking around.
Bellamy's Jr he's the third. Oh, the
problem. Mad. We're talking to his dad.
He's,
I'm sure Billy Mays was a good guy,
but didn't eat well. Yeah. He's
your friend. Whatever. Yeah.
That's why he couldn't respond
anyway. Dude was partying. Um,
the sham wow guy was the guy who got bit,
I tried to track it.
I actually think he bit someone. Yeah.
I'll look at it. Someone like Marv Albert.
Did Marv Albert Bite someone?
Yeah. Did he bite the lady?
I thought she bit him to
get my stories all confused.
He comes to dude dudes fighting too
many vaccines. That's your problem. That
they saved me from the measles,
but I got into a big fight with them.
They made me dumber. What happened? Oh,
there it is. Oh God. Oh, he bit her.
It's happened a few times I think with
shamwow pitch man. Brutal beat down. Yeah.
So they just went to war. Oh my God.
He did that to her eyes. Is that real?
I don't know what I mean, that might not
be real. That looks like makeup though.
That looks crazy. That's
like smoking. Yeah. No,
it didn't look like your makeup to
me. So symmetrical. Sorry. Black eyes.
That's what happens. Feet smashed in the
nose. That's the look. Make Up. You know,
she uh,
she had his tongue and so he started
punching her until she realized system.
Oh my God. Her hand on her mouth. Tongue
or in the consciousness in the face.
Oh my God. People are
crazy. That's math, right?
I had to guess what's involved there.
No, it's something crazy at the meth.
Really like PCP or like a on
bath salts. Oh, remember that?
If you're grabbing someone's tongue, it's
bath salts. Think Beth salts were Metho.
No. Yeah, I think it was,
I think what it was was math with the UN.
The,
I think they altered the molecule so
that it doesn't fall into the protected
schedule one drug c that you can
do things like that. Like, uh,
that's why DMT was illegal.
But five methoxy DMT wasn't,
which is actually stronger. Huh? Um,
what's that? Um, they missed that one.
Here it goes. What's that
drug? The last 10 minutes. Oh,
why does this best salts? I,
well, first of all, here's another thing.
I think there's a bunch of different kinds
of bath salts for sure. Yeah, for sure.
You got the lavender. I mean there's
got to get the lemon, but I mean nobody,
uh, I don't think anybody has a patent.
You can't call that bath salts. Wait,
cause that's all they got high on that
it's best salts. Cause the name bathy own.
It's no, no, no. The bath salts is cause
they were selling it in stores as Bateson.
Not for human consumption wick who end
up like you just planted the chemicals
bath he owed no, Kath. Oh,
I'll can I misread it. Okay.
But what I'm saying is that labeled
it bass also, they could sell it,
but everybody knew it was Matt.
Phil. Okay man. This bath salts over,
they should try smoking that.
But isn't that how Salvia
was around for a long time?
Salvia was around for the same reason.
Five methoxy DMT was around,
but I missed it in the sweeping
schedule. One drug, uh,
drug act of 1970 they missed that one.
Two of the most potent ones.
They missed Salvia divinorum
and five methoxy DMT.
And that's why they're always changing it.
Cause if it's slightly different than
you could say it's not that exactly.
So see if you find that like bath
salts is meth because someone,
there was a guy,
there was a guy who got a,
who's a homeless guy that
I think they shot him.
He was biting someone's face off in
Florida. Yeah. You remember that? Yeah.
And they said that he was on bath salts.
That's the first time I heard of it.
Yeah. And I think someone said
that it was meth that he was like,
cause like that cat stuff.
But it's like your thing,
it's just a bunch of different things.
You can call it a sound that
are made with mephedrone.
You could basically sell whatever you
want if you're selling it as not for human
consumption.
And also I'd probably,
they'd probably put smell into
it so they can say no. Well,
you know,
they probably threw some fucking,
so they have like a little cat and mouse
game going on for a while where they
would have a,
it's the same thing.
What's going on with that k
two spice stuff like yoga.
We have synthetic THC,
there were spraying all over it and stuff.
Supposed to be terrible for us. Awful.
Yeah. Way Worse for you than actual,
but they would outlaw one little chemical
and then those guys would figure out,
okay, tweak it and make a t
h three, seven, nine. Okay.
And now next week is three 80 and they
just would keep doing it every single
week literally.
And by the way,
that's the same shit that they did with
steroids with like the clear when Barry
bonds and all those
guys that balco scandal,
that's what all that stuff was about.
Oh,
they just changed the like the points
after the trucks and stuff around a little
and then it doesn't show up in this,
in the test because it's not the
thing that you're looking for.
The way it's been explained to me is
a lot of tests for things were very
specific. So when the testing for
something and it's just a little bit off,
I was like,
you test negative for it,
but it has a similar result or
approximate result in a different way,
Huh? Yeah. I will say
though, with the bath salts,
people were breaking into any
place that had them. Gas Stations,
any store that had bath salts, if
they think they had them, what?
Your windows are being broken.
Your doors are being broken.
You're not going to have that stuff
tomorrow. Yeah. Yeah. Those are methods.
That's meth head activity.
Jesus Christ. Do you knew what?
Did you ever know anybody?
There's a method. No. Yeah.
I haven't known a few people.
Uh, it's weird to see because it's a
visual. The results. Well, not always.
That's what's interesting,
what you're seeing when you see people
that are completely fucked up and picking
the skin off their face and they weigh
five pounds and they're falling apart.
That is worst case scenario.
There's some people that I would call
functional methods and what these people
are people that are on
amphetamines every day or
almost every day,
they're constantly on amphetamines.
So some of them get prescribed by doctors.
They get really irrational.
They start thinking that
everyone's out to get him. Um,
they get real mean and nasty towards other
people. Very defensive. They're always,
they're always attacking and thinking.
They're persecuted,
thinking that someone's attacking them.
It's very strange.
And these people could function like
this for years, years and years.
And you get the same with
the Adderall addicts. Yeah.
Yeah. But that's just speed,
isn't it? Same thing. Yeah. It's very
similar to math. It's amphetamines.
It's just a different release.
Like what Adderall is.
Duncan Trussell has a great joke is like
as if as a scientist took cocaine and
went,
I can fix this.
Just makes people talk
active and aggressive and
insulting and mean and nasty
because it like, it highlights some
of the worst aspects of people.
The bitchy pettiness. I love that stuff.
That's my bread and butter, but it's not,
that's why you do it. You do it with
a smile. Thank you. That's true.
Snarky people need to be having
more fun. Yeah, but you are,
your positions are always even fun
on agree with them. The rational.
I see your thought process. I see
where you're going. Well, thank you.
That's a huge compliment.
Not a method that well. Yeah.
Why do you say the Jews are doing what?
What's happening with the Nazis or one
big one? I guess. I interviewed uh,
a Nazi for the book and I
said to him, I go, look,
what do I supposed to do when they
see your people come at me and say,
the only reason you care about North
Korea and its concentration camps is
because they're anti Israel.
And he goes,
why do you want me to tell you there's
idiots? And every group as I'm like,
all right there separate because
they're anti Israel. Jeez.
The idea that Israel has to go through
with Korea, it's just absolutely amazing.
But I get that online people
connect to everything, right.
That are really into the
nutty conspiracies. There's
a network of connections.
So fall then if you're
not talking about it,
what they think is the
most important issue,
you're clearly being dishonest
because it's the most important issue.
Must be a shill.
Yes.
That time over there in Korea.
Interesting.
I did break American
[inaudible] over there,
North Korea. Hey, I wanted
to talk to you about this.
I don't know if you know
anything about it, but, um,
actually Google has pulled
the plug on Huawei today,
meaning they're no longer a allowing
android updates on waterway phones and
they're not allowing the Google app to
work on, on Walway phones or excuse me,
the g mail app to work on Walway phones.
If you had an old Walway phone with the
Gmail App, you're fine. But going forward,
no walkway phones will be
allowed to have a Gmail anymore.
W what's the reasoning? It's a very
good question. Uh, Marcus Brownley,
who's Marcus has been on the show before
and he's probably one of my favorite,
if not my favorite, um, tech reviewer on
youtube. He, uh, had a point about it.
He, you know, he put it up on his Twitter
and then I followed the feed. He's like,
this is very important. And I followed
a fee and there's tech people,
they're saying there is no reason
for this. There's no evidence.
Did not point to anything.
But then when I talked to people that
are experts in foreign policy and they
explain the way China works and China's
relationship between the government and
industry, how they're inextricably
connected and the, Oh yes,
every business works for the
government. They were saying, well no,
there's a reason why they're doing this.
Like this is the,
these guys are playing
in this real long game.
And to aid them in any way is
extraordinarily bad for our country.
Yeah. I had a Marian Smith when these,
you know, communism on my show and uh,
since my focus in North Korea, I
wasn't that much flux in China. And He,
and we all think in the West that,
you know,
China has gotten so much better than
it was, which is true, but he goes,
it's still really, really,
really bad. And one of the big,
I think fair criticisms or the corporate
press is how much their po focused on
Putin and Russia.
And it's like you calling him a dictator.
The shit they're pulling in China is an
order of magnitude worse and something
that they're doing now they
stole from North Korea.
North Korea has a southern called Sung
button and everyone on been s o n g B
when Sung won,
everyone in North Korea got interviewed
and there are several iterations of this
and you've got a score
based on your family.
So if you are family was born in
South Korea or a priest or land owner,
that's a low score.
If you,
your grandfather fought with the great
leader Kim Il Sung, that's a high score.
It's divided into favored class,
wavering and hostile and there's like
51 sub categories and this determines
everything about your life,
where you live,
where you go to college and is
China's now starting to do this.
They're trying to implement a social
credit system based on your loyalty to the
government,
which will allow things like leaving
the country and all sorts of other
opportunities and that's scary,
scary stuff and that's what needs to be,
I think covered much more in the west.
The problem with that as it becomes like
a game and people are going to want to
have a really high school.
Of course that's,
people are so weird when it comes
to score in games, but we get,
so you have to have a high score or else
you're not getting food. That's our job.
Right, right, right. Yeah. But
it's also like people covet it. Oh,
but they don't tell your score. Oh
Geez. You have to intimate it. Oh yeah.
It's scary. Oh yeah. Yeah.
So you got to fly. Right.
And so you're always nervous euro. That's
what they want. You're always nervous.
It's not a transparency
self-censoring as well. Yes.
It forces a system of self
censoring. Like Twitter. Yes.
Are you saying that Twitter is like China?
Did you just say that Twitter's like
communism, those words? Yes. No,
we've got a ways to go for communism,
but some of the techniques they use are
very disturbingly totalitarian. Yes.
Disturbingly. So. And the other thing
is yes, they are a private company.
It's funny how the left is like,
as soon as you criticized Twitter,
they're private company. They can do
they want, but any other private company,
whatever it,
a private company can be criticized.
And if you know you're were perfectly
appropriate in a free market to say what
you're doing is screwed up and give us
answers or we're going
to use another company.
I think when I talked to Jack about this,
one of the things that he was saying is
that they're considering an open Twitter,
like they're going to have Twitter
where it's like a safe neighborhood and
Twitter where it's like the wild west.
Okay. And I said please do that. Yeah.
I said please do that. You know, I
mean if he does is to block people,
there's ways to avoid people. Black
people liberally. You know, it's weird.
They'll block lists when you never
even had an interaction with someone.
It's like a black list. Yeah. And you
go to their page and their blocked,
you're just blocked.
Just [inaudible] reasons.
People have block lists for anyone
who follows president Trump. Yeah.
And it's like if I'm a journalist,
yeah.
I sure as hell better be falling the
fucking precedent right now. He's saying,
first of all, he says hilarious shit.
Yes. On the reg. Look, he does do.
What's your favorite Trump tweet? Rocket
Man, when he was calling my favorite one.
Hold on, Jim. John Own Rocky man. What's
the one about the haters and the losers?
Yes, that's a great one. But he
did that before he was president.
It was like 2013 it's still my
favorite Trump tweet by far. Oh yeah.
Every time I speak of
the haters and losers,
I do so with great love and affection.
They cannot help the fact
that they were born fucked up.
I would like if he said
that now as president.
I know that's one thing he's really doing.
Done a great job as president,
not swearing. Yeah, it's amazing. Well,
did you see what CNN did to him
during the campaign? He said, boy,
that's really up.
So he didn't say it.
They played the clip that they believed
him. Yes. We talked about this before.
Yeah. It's very dishonest. Yeah.
They bleeped it to make it look like
he said something that he didn't did,
but he's cursing blue streak in the
White House. Anyway, we all know this,
but it's funny. I liked it. I think
that part is funny, like I'm not,
I'm not happy with a
lot of what's going on,
but I'm very happy that
he's this ridiculous person.
I think it's funny and I think it's very
healthy for us to have less reverence
for the president because when
a precedence on a pedestal,
he's in a position to send
our sons and daughters to die.
Whereas if you look at him as a clown,
you're going to be much less,
more skeptical of, is this man
going to war for the right reasons?
Is he doing these things for the right
reasons? And I think that's very,
and that's what the
founding fathers wanted to,
they didn't want the president
to be looked at as a god. Yeah,
that's an interesting point that I think
you're correct and I think this idea
that it's behavior unfitting for a
president, that's what we're thinking,
that a president is a special person,
very special job,
and they'll act accordingly like a
gentleman. And they're human beings.
It's a stupid job.
It's a ridiculous job for anyone.
You saw Biden went after Trump and says,
oh, being presidential is always, yeah,
by definition he's always
being presidential cause
he's the fucking president
and you're not well Biden's a weird guy.
Do you see all this videos?
Him Sniffing those kids?
Oh, what is that about?
I mean it could just
be a sweet old grandpa,
but switch some sweet old GRANDPA's
don't want to fuck kids. They do do that.
The thing is it would in a sense be
make more sense to people if he was just
like Hanzi right. It's like okay,
you're all right. Right. This is like,
I don't even know where to put this.
Right. Where do you put sniffing? Yeah,
it's so fucking weird thing.
He's just a weird guy.
Did you know about um,
the,
the plagiarism from back when he was
running for president? He ran three times.
Yeah. I think he's fucked in the primary
because his track record is pathetic.
So the first time you ran was an 88
cycle, right? He announced this in July.
He has to fold by September cause
this plagiarism scandal, right.
He runs again in oh eight comes in
like what sixth in Iowa has to pull.
So he, in terms of his history of
running for presidency, it's been very,
very poor. He's a good backup man. He's
like right, right. Cause you steady,
reliable results. Yeah. Stay
the fuck out this look it's,
they're going to eat him alive.
It's ugly. It's going to be ugly.
You're going to hate it bro. And you're
not going to win. They're getting the,
I don't think he's going
to raise the front runner.
And you look at the democratic polls in
terms of the Democrats who was a fun run
or at this point in 2003 Oh Joe Lieberman.
Ah,
because he was the vice presidential
candidate from Gore. You,
everyone knew his name. What happened
with that guy? He lost and he reads.
He went right, didn't he? He, he lost
the primary in his State of Connecticut.
Then he ran as an independent
Democrat one again, I got elected,
he killed universal health care cause
they needed 60 votes and he's like,
fuck you, we're not doing it. So they
had to have this Obamacare market system.
It's because of him and
now everyone hates him.
Didn't he turn it into a Republican
though? No. No. But he endorsed the,
became a Nazi [inaudible] Joe Lieberman,
Joe Lieberman,
invention peer or Nazis.
Yet God sees the new, right.
Yeah.
The fact that he gets called one,
that's the funniest shit ever while I
was wearing a Yamaka people calling them
or not. So that you'd never
suspected. Yeah. Sneaky. We're sneaky.
I just think if we had to
design a system from scratch,
there's no way we'd have one person
at the top of the pyramid. Right.
Doesn't make any sense. It doesn't
need to be a pyramid. Yeah. Doesn't,
it could be a series of silos.
Yeah. No reason. I mean,
I guess the good thing would be that
person can veto stuff and get things done.
So if there is some sort of,
if he's a reasonable person and he
really works well with those and doesn't
abuse that power, one
thing he has done, those,
the what I mean, I'm just going
to sound ridiculous, but when he,
as Kim Kardashian bring in cases of
people that were unjustly prosecuted,
are unjustly imprisoned and he releases
them. I liked that. I liked it.
She does it and I liked that. He does.
It takes a lot for me to get angry.
But when people were clowning
them and I'm like Kim Kardashian,
you can say a lot of shit about her.
She saved people's lives.
She's helping people in a tremendous way.
You're going to tell those families
that Kim Kardashian is, fuck you.
She's helped 17 people be released
from prison in the last three months.
And I think it's also
very disturbing how Glib,
a lot of people are about
prison and it's a really,
I don't know what it's like and I
don't want to know what it's like.
You don't want, it's no joke. Yeah.
But it is a punchline and it's like
you're laughing about people being
traumatized for life and possibly
having no possibility of returning into
society if this is,
people used to be able to laugh about
stuff like that cause it would be like
laughing at work, you know, you
go to work and you're like, hey,
oh Jay's in the can and he's going to
take it into care and you would go to work
and you'd say something stupid like
that and it wouldn't go anywhere.
But when you say something like that
on Twitter or Facebook like oh boy,
you remember. Um, I mean people find
out and you say the inappropriate thing.
You remember that with
Justine sacco south.
I was flying here for this show and
someone tweet at me Hashtag has malice
landed yet because that was
the Hashtag for her. Oh yeah.
Cause she tweeted out a joke.
She gets out of flight and it blew up
while she was on the flight and when she
lands where life is going
down for a dumb joke.
Yeah. That jump, Joe could have been
something that you would just say.
And then the next day be like,
oh, the fuck is wrong with me.
I was on Ambien and alcohol
and trying to be funny.
And that is something that the
evangelical left is very scary about,
about being,
about if you're tea,
if you take a joke and that's
inappropriate in some sense,
and they're the ones judging, it's
inappropriate. Your life should be ruined.
That is crazy. And a totalitarian. Yeah,
it's um,
it's also,
it smacks of deep insecurity and fear
that you experienced personally and you
want to turn it on other people.
The same feeling that people
have when they're bullies.
The reason why someone's a bully is almost
always because they're not confident
of their own abilities.
So they want to somehow or another
by being cruel to someone else,
they exercised this power on someone
else and it's somehow or another relieves
them of a certain portion
of this inadequacy. They
feel the stress they feel.
That's why one of the reasons why a
lot of people are saying that bullies,
contrary to like what would
think would be a logical thing.
You should teach them how
to fight and they wouldn't,
they wouldn't want to do this.
The reason why they're doing this
to people's cause, they're insecure.
And that's the same thing
I think when you're,
when you see these Twitter moms
and people at attacking people,
the thing they fear most is that
they're going to be attack themselves.
The thing that they feel,
what they feel, social ops,
they fear social ostracization the fee.
They fear that the theory being standing
up on their own two feet and being an
individual.
And I have a whole chapter on dark humor
in this book and I was shocked that
they let me publish it because Bobby
McFarland, great comedian, she has, she,
she was roasting Jim Norton and she
says to him, uh, your show is selling,
listen to bubble. I'd rather hear
my daughter drowning. And it's like,
are you going to 12 it?
But let's say let's break this down.
Are you going to tell her as a comedian
or as a mom that that's not appropriate?
She, so far they only made me cut one
joke. I have everything else in there.
And the point I make is something
might not be funny for you if you're an
assault victim. Right. You don't
want to kind of thought that's right,
but it's not,
that means something's not
for you. Doesn't mean it's
not for anyone. What is, uh,
the new, right? This is the,
the title of your book. Yeah.
A journey to the fringe of American
politics. What, what inspired you? Uh,
so the circles I was swimming in started
going into developing to the scene as
it was happening that culminated in like
the Trump presidency in Charlottesville.
So I was there as this was happening.
What circles we discussing this kind
of the anarchist circles, the, the uh,
what they call 'em race realism,
the racist, you know, uh,
the alt right and seeing
a lot of it happening.
Just being discussed in the press and
people not knowing what they're talking
about. I'm like, all right,
someone's got to write this book who's
been there and understands it and it
might as well be, how do you
understand it? Like what, what,
what about at doing the race
realist? Because I, the,
one of the points I make is this is not
one scene where everyone's in agreement.
These people often completely
hate each other and disagree.
The only thing that unites them is
there opposition to progressivism.
And this is you looking at this as a
journalist when you say, sure. Yeah.
With the way you're saying it is like
you're a part of these groups. Well,
I was the, I, I, I'm like, all right,
I went to all the meetings, you know,
I'd go to Charlottesville and interviewed
all the types I had. I, you know,
and it's what their points of view are.
And if you're gonna engage
with this kind of thinking,
which is somewhat
prevalent on the fringes,
you have to at least understand where
they're coming from and being dismissive.
And that gets a power for sure.
But what I want to say is,
cause I don't want people to misconstrue
you so someone could listen to this and
inadvertently misscans or
purposely misconstrue and
think that you're a part of
these groups. Oh No, no. So it's very
clear in this book who I agree with that.
Absolutely. Yeah. In the book,
but the way we're discussing
it in this conversation,
you're saying the circles that you run in.
Yeah.
Cause a lot of the people who I was
friends with fell down this rabbit hole.
They fell down the rabbit
hole of Nazi-ism racism. Yes.
And that's who you were friends with
fell down. I'm not naming. Yeah, because,
and it was very disturbing them
in real life. Correct. Wow.
And it was very disturbing to watch as
they start throwing our terms like HPD
and Rx, human biodiversity, that's their
code word for different races. Right.
Schuman, biodiversity is the code
word for different races. Yes.
And what's the other one?
HBS and NRX anorexia reaction.
So this is basically a,
America has this decadent,
why my republic and we need to
return to like hardcore, right.
Euro reaction. Neo, neo,
neo, neo reaction. That's,
that was the Hashtag before was the
outright, it's not the same buddy.
They similar enough. So, and a lot
of these guys are really cerebral.
You know, they could tell you
about the history of England.
They could tell you about, you know, all
the science and Swat went wrong. Uh, with,
with, with whom? With them. I,
I don't know what went wrong.
I think one of the things that goes
wrong is when no one's talking to you and
you're just talking to each other,
you're going to start doubling down
because there's no one hitting the brakes.
You know what else happens, what
you say controversial things. People
attack you and then some
people don't attack you.
They support you and then you gravitate
towards those people that support you.
Right? And then you get that endorphin
rush. You Get the light. Yes.
You start seeing that with people and
they started embracing really weird fringe
ideas.
They become a part of these fringe groups.
They get praised by these fringe
groups and then the elevate to,
to virtue signal for that fringe group.
And so at a,
you could be either an average person
in the mass or you could be a leader in
the fringe.
So it's a big fish in a small pond and
you can be one of those who knows one of
those who knows, right. People
know what the fuck is going on.
So not going to get me with the scam.
So my line is you take one red
pill but not the whole bottle.
You take the Adderall Bro, the
fucking Adderall. No one's going to,
I know what's happening.
Start stashing weapons in your backyard.
Prepping. Yeah. Yeah. It's an interesting,
and there's also a long
history of this stuff.
So how did you know those guys in real
life? Did you know them from work?
Did you know from like uh, like
Antarctica circles? So yeah,
this anarchy thing. Like how
serious are you about that? 100%.
100% serious. So anarchists think
there should be no cops. No, Eric is,
don't think they should be government
cops. They should be private security. Oh,
private security for what?
Well, same thing you,
no one wants to have a scenario.
Like if you go to a bar,
you're not paying for the
doorman or if go into a hotel,
you're not paying for the security.
The point is whoever has an environment
wants it to be as safe as possible for
stop right there. Okay. Cause if you go
into a bar, if you're buying a drink,
the bar is taking some of the money from
that drink to pay for that security.
Correct. It's the same thing as you paying
taxes. It's not the same thing as you.
Pink texts. Let's just look at it
this way. It's just money into a pool.
It's not just money. Please. If
you throw the money into a pool,
but do you need me to, let me
explain. Okay. If you throw
the money into the pool.
Okay. And the obviously taxes get taken
from you. It's different in that regard.
But if you have a certain amount of money,
certain amount of money's going
to go to protecting the people.
And this is the idea of police force
and this is the idea of a bouncer or at
least a bouncer is more likely acting
in the interest of the club share and
trying to keep out bad people and try
and keep people from getting sued.
But the money for the drinks goes to that.
Some of it,
a percentage of it goes to
that much like your tax money.
Some of it goes to the
cops. Sure. Right, correct.
But the big difference is one is
voluntary and one is forceful and one is a
monopoly and one isn't.
So if you had an a three system,
you would have more security because
the streets would have someone doing
security and the bar and the store and
there would be complimentary to each
other as opposed to you only have to
dial nine one one wouldn't have it.
Look how many dating sites.
They're all right.
Wouldn't it be great if instead of one
number you had dozens of places that are
gonna offer you security. So like
private businesses that work like Uber,
you give him a call when you're getting
raped unless you press a button has
short one with the dude was we had on
you press a button and then someone shows
up. We have that now. We have now.
I mean if you go to an apartment
building or a business building,
there is going to be security
there already. You're not gonna,
you're not going to call the cops.
You're going to call the downstairs.
We'll just book readers. Sure. You're
sitting there playing with their phone.
They used to be book readers
to other phone players. Well,
I'd rather they be reading books than
shooting dogs. So that's where we are.
Right. I see what you're saying in
terms of that's the grossest shit ever.
When you see swat teams show up and
shoot people's dogs when people get,
and that's the problem with having a
monopoly is there's no consequences.
So let's say there's all these cases
where, you know, dogs get shot,
the flash grenade and the
baby's crib. Yeah. These
people aren't fight like a, um,
Eric Gardner,
the only person who got in trouble for
Eric Garner dying is the guy who filmed
it.
I mean,
if you are a cook and you are serving
food and you under cook chicken,
it's a mistake, honest mistake and someone
gets sick. That shouldn't be your job.
But if you're a police officer often,
and I'm going to get a lot of heat
for this, and that's fine. Uh,
if you see something bad happens
as a consequences for actions,
there have to be consequences that
maybe this isn't the right job for you.
We'll oftentimes a ruse if they're sure
in inappropriate shooting or supplying
those lines. But I think you're right
and mean. I've experienced abusive cops.
I think we all have. And I also
think that it's very, very,
very difficult to be that guy.
Absolutely.
And not become abusive and
not become worn out by it,
not become extremely stressed out.
I'm a big supporter of police.
I just don't think that
it's a job for everybody.
I think being a cop is like
a lot of other jobs that are,
especially that one that's
super fucking difficult.
The idea that you just hire people off
the street and run them through some
tests and they're gonna make great
cops. I agree. It's crazy. I agree.
And then what happens is
when you're a monopoly,
you don't have to be
efficient or effective.
I think they should hire former military.
That's what I think have that
at least they hire people, know,
hire people that have disciplined,
hire people that,
that have gone through some
experience in actual combat,
who know how to handle pressure
better and then make it a very,
very valuable job and make it a very
like very strict codes of conduct and
behavior and action.
I think another problem that police
have in their defense is when you have
public streets, people uh, have
certain rights and they can act,
have where they were like, here in
la you have all these, these tents.
And I thought,
my understanding is the government
said you can't clear out those tents.
That is hilarious, isn't it? And
now the cops can't do anything.
So they are hamstrung for
being able to do their jobs.
Whereas if this was private, this
would not be happening. Well,
if you go under underpasses and La folks,
I don't know where you live,
but there's a fucking campground that
literally they have tents everywhere.
I went to see, I didn't know skid row
was an actual place. I didn't know.
I went there last time I was
here and they were, they,
the whole block is covered intense. Oh, it
was unbelievable. People who don't know,
uh, I love to take them to skid row.
It's just amazing. Downtown La is insane.
Like you go there and you're like, what
is this? Well, what this is, is failure.
This is failure. I mean, cultural failure,
failure to address these
members of our community.
Fair failure to provide health care,
failure to raise children correctly.
Failure to keep people from drugs,
failure to provide good systems
to get them off of drugs.
It started in New York to de Blasio.
Who's a real charmer that one.
Like now all you go
into every subway train,
there's a homeless person
with all their bags and this,
there's got to be better alternatives
than that. Even for them. Well,
there's somewhat,
oh,
Donald Trump jr posted videos all over
the news the other day when he was
talking about the de Blasio and he's
like, this is, I'm driving here. I'm,
LIZ is out my window and filming and
look good. Look at all these tents.
Like he look at all those homeless shit.
He started following me
on Twitter and now, uh,
I live in fear of like saying the
wrong thing again. I don't know.
It's just like holy shit because North
Korea is my biggest issue by far.
Right by far.
But what are you in fear of?
Like getting on followed by Donald
Trump Jr. Yeah. She ain't got long fall.
You well, he better not. No. I have
friends that are friends with him. Okay.
Like good friends, like my good friends
and they're good friends with him. Okay.
I'll slide in. Tastes like
him. They say he's a good guy.
Just a slide into his dms. Do it so
weird. He's just in a weird position, man.
If he wasn't the, the president's son,
he wouldn't be under so much scrutiny.
You'd be like, oh, he's a great guy.
It's like everybody's just like, oh,
you're the president's son. But it's
weird for me, given that that was my beat,
that I'm like one step away from being
able to influence policy in that issue,
which is the most important
thing to me. But again, it, yeah.
What would you tell them
about North Korea? Uh, I mean,
I wouldn't even know where to start.
I would just,
I would think I'd have a
lot of information about
helping with the psychology,
how to kind of influence them, how to
basically, uh, manipulate them, uh,
also how evil they truly,
really and truly are.
I'd always to keep that in mind.
So it's a dance.
It's a very delicate dance with them.
Um,
do you think he's going to get
in trouble with Russia? Who,
which one don't Trump jr? Yeah. You think
he will? I don't know. I don't think so.
I don't think so. Yeah. Thing
anybody's, I think it's over.
I don't think it's Alpha. It's not, I
don't think it's over it because people,
if after three years of reporting now
you can say with a straight face what,
there were three years of reporting over
nothing. If there's smoke, there's fire,
you know, blah, blah, blah. So I
haven't been following it that closely.
I saw Justin Amash,
you know,
just tweeted out that he had this whole
tweet storm that he thinks Trump should
be impeached based on who was that? Justin
Amash is a congressman from Michigan.
He's uh, uh, uh, one of like
three libertarians and he turned,
he said, he's like, I
actually read the report,
which most people have not in Washington.
He'd hundred pages, is it? Yeah.
And he's like, I think this is, there's
stuff in here that's impeachable. Whoa,
this was a big deal. And then all
the left, we're like republic.
Even Republicans like Justin Amash is
like, no, no. It's just him. It's not,
there's no, like it's him. It's
literally just hit save him. Yeah.
There's only two like him.
It's Thomas it like them.
It's Thomas Massie and likely that's the
three of them. And Ran Paul for rand.
Paul's an interesting cat.
I like him. Well, I was, uh,
I want to talk to his neighbor that fucked
him up. Oh, that's such a bitch move.
Don't be such a bitch.
That
is such a bitch. Tackled him when he
wasn't even looking. I know. Yeah.
I think he had earphones on to
it's, it's uh, uh, I'm gonna,
I'm not sitting here like some Badass,
but come on. What the fuck are you doing?
Yeah. How about that guy that
kicked Arnold Schwarzenegger? Yes.
That was hilarious. He kicked this kid,
dropped, kicked Arnold towards the nigger.
I think he was crazy. South Africa. He
was saying he was screaming out. Help me.
I need a Lamborghini.
While they were arresting him,
it was the bath salts. Worldstar
hip hop made it. He's on. Look,
I mean, if that's what he want, look
what really happened to Arnold. Nothing.
What's really gonna Happen to that kid?
Probably go to jail for a couple.
Actually, I don't know. You don't know
South Africa. Look at, look at, uh,
Ottawa beer in North Korea.
He steals a sign in and he's dead.
So you don't know what the laws
like in South Africa could be.
Think it's not as bad as North Korea.
That's not a status North Korea
come on y'all. It's not a to guard.
Fucked him up pretty well too. Then
it looked like it. Two seconds.
Let's say if your, if your drop kicking
people out of nowhere. That's the problem.
When I was talking to Eddie Izzard,
Eddie ran a bunch of marathons
in South Africa. 20 was,
it was to sell to do,
it was a designation.
It was the same numbers, the amount of
years that Nelson Mandela was in prison,
social 27. Um, so he ran 27 marathons,
but there was areas where they're like,
listen man,
you ain't running through here like
this is this area we want to go to.
We're going to take you,
I'm going to put you in a car.
We're going to drive you
way the fuck past here.
And then you keep running when
you're not running through here.
Like you'll get killed, you'll get,
you'll get your gift Card Jack. This is,
we're all gonna get shot. You're not
going through here. And that's, you know,
there's parts of the world that are
like that and on Swartz and Egor when he
visited South Africa,
what's the worst you've got?
Drop kicked in with poor technique.
Okay.
Want to say to the kid had no follow
through, right? Barely knocked a 71 year.
First of all, even though Arnold
Sports Center, 71 years old,
he's still a 71 year old Arnold's wards,
and of course he's still at tank,
but I mean even fall over kid drop cam,
he didn't even know it was coming. Right.
He gets hit in the middle of this guy
and he's fine. It's kind of
impressive. I got your precedent.
You do? What do you got? Ready? Okay.
What do you like best about me? Uh,
get to fuck this up. I got this,
this system as Joe Rogan thing.
That's like a thing of girl says to you,
right? She's about to trap you. What?
That's the intellect. Your
personality. I like everything.
This is the most Joe Rogan thing I've
ever found. What is it? Here you go. Well,
we got here.
Take it.
What is that?
It's a mini museum set.
It's got 29 different things from all
over the universe in Cayston. Lucite. Wow.
That is fucking dope. Yeah. Wow.
Got a piece of the White House.
A piece of the Hollywood
sign is some Amazon water.
A giant sloths claw. I think. Wow.
Thank you. You are welcome to.
That'll go right fucking here. Yeah.
Here's the book to tell Centrelink
about it. Thank you. Very cool. That's,
where'd you find this?
I want them one of my rabbit holes in
the Internet and I'm like, Holy Shit.
This will be perfect. Gel Internet
rabbit holes. Oh, that's dope, dude.
Thank you very much. Um, so you
get the velvet bag. Oh yeah. Oh,
this is a bag for it. All the bag. I
feel like I needed to have it out though.
The bag right here, I got mine
on display desk is so cluttered.
This is a ridiculous to ever keep
saying I'm going to clean it up.
It's not going to happen. Yeah. So tell
me more about your book and why you,
why you breaking. Um, these buildings.
Is that, that's a dog whistle.
That's a dog was to cover.
So there's a guy named Ben Garrison and
he was a regular conservative artist.
Right. And he would have drawings about
like Ben Bernanki or Hillary or whatever.
The Nazis took his art,
replaced all of his drawings with Jews.
So instead of the great
wizard or debt being the Fed,
it was a Jewish caricature
and they did it perfectly.
And they also invented this
whole backstory about him
that he was this closet
Nazi and this poor guy in Montana, if
you Google him, it's like not to end.
He's like, why is this happening to
me? And the Photoshop work is perfect.
So eventually they
calmed down and you know,
he now he's kind of like a regular
cartoonist and the story got out.
But that's his artwork.
So the people that,
this poor guy who is talking
about a victim of Nazis,
it's very rare nowadays to have a new
victim of Nazis and he's actually one of
them. Well, meme culture is
very strange, right? Yes.
And those little humorous images
that get chucked around. Oh yeah.
There's a lot of dirt bags that have
really profited off of other people's meme
work to my, like my friend
Don, he's terrible. He works,
he works for a meme site.
Yeah, sorry, I'll turn it
back. Those sites are bad, man.
Some of them just flat out steal and
some of them steal and then they'll
attribute, yeah. Somewhere.
Like they'll just say your name and
sometimes they don't even say your name.
They say unnamed of like a fake account.
That doesn't even just it
just attributed to someone.
Oh we thought we got it from that
person because they know that it's at a
hundred different accounts cause a bunch
of people have this guy's like you,
you'll find something and you're like,
oh this is funny and you put it up.
But then these people that they make
these giant sites with all other people's
work and they curate them and they make
millions. Yep. Like the fat Jewish. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Everyone hates him. Yeah. This,
this is one of this is like one of your
big issues with like people who like
take content and basically it'd be,
it'd be appropriate for themselves
first for sure would stand up comedy.
But the thing that's happening
with memes is like you're, you,
if someone sends you something,
like there's a bunch of things that my
f like Eddie Bravo sends me hilarious
ones all the time.
He'll send me a funny meme and then I'll
send it to Brendan shop and like I'm
not asking who made that
mean. Right. So it's a joke.
Brendan doesn't think
that I made it myself.
So it's not like I'm stealing that joke,
but I'm definitely not
crediting the original creator
cause I don't know who the
fuck it
is. Right. And those things
fly around, they flyer out. So,
but that's all with in good faith.
The person was in bad faith,
right.
Curates a website and then
starts profiting off of it.
They find a loophole and then they make
deals with comedy central and they also
have people who actually steal standups
bits and turn those bits in the memes
and they put those bits on there, their
meme pages and they do the same shit.
They'll do it. They just, their content
needers they need content. They're whores.
Parasites. Yes. So they just,
they'll hire people to do it. They,
they in the people that they hire,
they'll,
they'll steal people's jokes and
tournament into memes. I mean it's real.
It's a real problem.
That's, that's, that's, I
mean, that's like become a
joke because people were like,
oh, this is a rare pepe. Right. As cause
like please save it. It's just like,
you know, even though you can
replicate it into the lab,
a lawsuit lawsuits going on, right.
I talk about that in there. Oh No.
The new one that's happening right now,
Alex Jones refused to,
he refused to settle out of court.
So they're going to go to court.
They're going to figure out whether or
not peppy can, you can use pepe the frog.
But I mean, I talk about this
in the context of, it's like,
can you Andy Warhol use a Campbell soup
can. It's the same thing. It's like, it's,
yeah, someone creates it. But
if someone is using it in it,
kind of a broader satirical context,
what it doesn't though,
because Andy probably couldn't
do that today. Yes, he could.
I think that assume if you tried to
make a lot of money off of Campbell soup
cans, corporations had more power
back then unless, uh, accountability.
Because now with social media, if I want
to lose their minds on Campbell's, right.
That's true. That's a
good point. I think that,
do you know what they did with
Campbell's did when he did this,
he paints all 40 flavors of soup cans,
right? Puts them up in a gallery.
Campbell's is like, what the fuck is this?
Like they didn't know what to do. Right.
And they didn't know who to call it.
This is unprecedented.
So they had a storefront and they
had the cans out the window. They go,
why pay a hundred grand?
You could get a here for a dollar.
So they tried to own it in their
own way. That's smart. That's smart.
Great advertising for them. Yeah.
I mean gigantic advertising.
But that's the other thing is like with
this meme culture, people like, oh,
pepe means white supremacy.
It's like you can't,
Campbell's doesn't say what
a Campbell soup can means.
Different things mean this is not news.
Different things mean different
things to different people.
And if you're using it in one context
doesn't mean other contexts aren't
legitimate. That's how
art and images work. Yeah.
I mean that's almost like what happened
with the guy in Montana, right?
He takes his work and then turns into
Nazi stuff and then all the sudden he
becomes a Nazi. Right. And that's what
they do with it. With pepe the frog.
Cause that guy who met here.
Yeah. Oh he's so upset. I know.
Cause he know what they did to him log.
Do you know if they did to him?
He had a cartoon where he killed peppy.
So all the trolls are like,
oh that's interesting.
So they took all his other characters
and made them full blow Nazis.
So Heinrich,
who's the wolf,
instead of having reflections in a
sunglasses had the SS, they're like,
oh you want to, you want to throw
it out, we'll throw down asshole.
And that's what ended up happening to him.
Wolf has a name already now they gave
him the last name. It's like Heinrich,
something else. But that name,
I'll tell you what. Oh my
God, I, no, no, no. This is,
what do they call it? That's a Nazi
wolf. Sounds like a Nazi war navy. They,
what was the guy's hilarious that he
thought he could just kill it off.
That's like d platforming. He thought
he was going to d platform. Pepe.
Let's also like,
let's suppose I decided to kill off
Paul Bunyan put the fuck are you,
how does that mean?
It doesn't mean anything.
Like the idea that he's going to
kill it off and they're going to say,
oh well we killed the dog.
His name was originally land wolf,
so they said,
oh,
his first name is Heinrich land wolf
and the you pull it up and the glass as
well. Maybe we shouldn't have that
assessed the damage right here,
but land wolf as opposed to sky wars.
Fuck does that mean, the funny
thing is about pepe? It was,
it was always so bland in lame.
Well I think for,
it was adopted as a meme. Like when
you see like feels bad man, right?
Like it was like, Whoa, this is
so low. Blood sugar bothers me.
But it's also the idea of, you're
saying that because Nazis are using it,
you can't use it as feels bad man.
Like if you're giving it okay symbol
and they're using it this way,
you can't say, oh that's
okay as make any sense. Yeah.
You can't say something to me. I
go, okay my mouse if I do that,
that's white supremacy. No, everybody.
For years I had a whole series on my
Instagram page of people doing the okay
sign. Of course, including me back
when I had earrings, it was radio days.
Bill Cosby doing the okay symbol.
It's fucking, come on man.
You guys know this is not,
that's not what this is.
Just because people are using it and
saying it is. And they were investigating.
People were investigating people.
There was a guy who is on television,
they blurt it out.
Yeah.
And the other thing is we're at a point
now where it's more easy to give the
finger to someone than to say,
okay,
yeah cause you blur the finger out and
nobody cares. But if you do that like, oh,
what is he doing?
He's touching his fingers.
You can't even do like you're holding
a joint cause that's like a white power
giant. Like if you're like doing
that like a roach, that's bad.
That's bad. How do you, do
you have to use a roach clip?
It's a ploy by the roach clip industry.
But there's, I have a list in their world,
the things that are called racist milk
show dinosaurs milk become racist.
Oh cause the,
the what the trolls do is they make it,
let's see if we get them freaking out
about milk and they got it. Picnics.
My favorite one the trolls did was the
free bleeding movement. I'm like God,
that's the greatest thing that people
who've ever accomplished that they
actually got women. No, no,
no, no. You're, there's two
things. You're confusing.
Two things.
The free bleeding was a woman who made it,
but there was the pee on yourself
and there was no free bleeding.
Was a four Chan Chantrel no, it was
the girl running a race cause she was,
she was actually smart about it.
She said this is to create awareness
toward women in third world countries who
don't have access to
sanitary pads. I, yeah,
I was reading a whole
article on the four Chan,
the creating the free bleeding
movement. Okay. I could be wrong.
See if he could pull that out.
I
know there was a legitimate
example of the free bleeding. Yeah,
I think that was post that on putting it
up. They've done a few things like that.
They all said, pee on yourself
to fight rape. Oh, I heard.
Because that's one of the big
arguments that to fight a rapist,
that you're actually in that situation,
pee on yourself,
that'll turn them away and it's like you
shouldn't give people advice. It's like,
listen,
if she's actually getting assaulted,
what should she do in that
horrible circumstance?
And then it's like pee on yourself to
show your support for victims sexual
assault.
Wasn't there a senator or somewhere that
actually said that if it's a legitimate
reason that's in there, and Todd Aiken,
Todd Akin was run, this is amazing.
Todd Akin was running for
Senate in Missouri and he's
prolife and they asked him
a very common question for
life people. What about if
it's rape? And he goes, well,
that's very rare. And it
goes, but my understanding is
a, if a woman is assaulted,
the body has a way of shutting it down.
Now there's a book called sperm
wars and apparently an, again,
I'm crazy scientists don't get mad at me.
Didn't work. That's the book's not legit.
Is that true? No, no. It's been disputed.
It's been debunked. Okay, thank you.
Is there is no evidence that sperm
acts as anything other than sperm that
attacks the egg and tries to get up
pregnant. The claiming that book, Yeah.
Is that rape is more likely to result
in pregnancy than regular intercourse.
The point is, he got red out of town
on a rail, uh, and then Reza Aslan,
who said on Twitter, you know
what? I hope he gets raped.
And if you take his
comment out of context,
it's very disturbing and it's
kind of disturbing in context.
But Rez response being like, this is
a response to you being like, yeah,
you've got raped or not
going to get pregnant.
And he got the new right one after him,
Reza and got him fired
from CNN years later.
Is that what he got fired from?
He also called the present and a shithead.
So they're like,
they use that and they use the
other tweet and they gave it to him.
What's free, really free
bleeding stuff has been online.
There's an article I
found from 2004 Oh crap.
So it's been online for a long time,
but as we started it,
four Chan picked it up as a troll in
2014 okay. Say started as a real thing.
It's been a thing online now for
a long time on feminist blogs.
I'll 2011 there's another
thing when you fuck,
but when you find in 2004 was it a
troll? No, it was all about my vagina.
My badge.net. Yeah, I
told you we'd do a new,
I'm glad I got this right. Okay.
You got it right to my badge.
Fortunate has too much
power long [inaudible] dot
net some ladies experienced
with her free bleeding, so she just
lets her 15 years ago, her twat bleed.
Oh sorry. That's okay. You got that one.
The article was so fucking convincing.
That's a problem man. It's a Pr,
you know and that's what
people in that are arguing for.
D platforming are saying when
they're like for d platforming,
anti vaxxers or d platforming,
flat earthers or anybody
who's got information that's
just not accurate in terms
of,
the other thing is climate change.
Yeah. Hold on. Pick one.
My big answer is you guys reported WMDs
for a long time and hundreds of thousand
people got killed because
of this misinformation.
So if that's going to be your standard,
you're going to have two d platform,
the New York Times as well. So
it's a very, a double edged sword.
When you start talking about
if people give misinformation,
they have to be banned from
these social media sites.
You need someone to be able to check the
orthodox point of view no matter what
it is. It's true. There's no denying that.
What does [inaudible] this is the poster.
That's the key.
I didn't know this was about a poster.
It's a fair use issue with
the peppy and Alex Jones.
[inaudible] upon certain, like they're
arguing as fair use and he's arguments,
not blah, blah, blah. So interesting.
It's not just because it's
a meme or something. Yeah.
There's the poster person behind
Alex to l a to the left of Alex.
All right. He's going to question.
Most of these people are,
I know who all of them.
I don't know if that's like a cigarette
in their hand or a test tube or a tampon.
What does that, what does that,
is that a blunt? What does that,
so the Sharpie is that you're
writing something on Alex's back.
Is that a dude or a guy? Who the fuck is
that? Who is that? I know everybody else.
Whatever. We could be here for days.
Is that the diamond and silk? Okay.
Is that lady, I think that was so, I
don't know. It must be diamond and silk.
The two of them whose diamond and so
there are these two black ladies who are
Trump's biggest fans.
And they go to social media and
they start ranting or raving.
I've seen one and that one of them always
drinks blue line blue wine and it's
like when you're so sick
of his blue bullshit,
they just drinking literal Koolaid.
It's blue. She's got a blue liquid.
It's crazy green one here and
she's a Trump. It's racist.
Well, wait a minute. Maybe she's
drinking coolers like do you can get,
can you get Green Koolaid? No,
I think it's wine. Wine glass.
I think they have blue line. Now what?
Let's look at the looks on her face.
She's always seemed sad.
I don't know what you want is diving
for when Silk One zero always act really
upset the other month. Just like,
why am I here? That's a good move.
If you just want attention.
If you don't really support Trump,
I can sit in there with the Green
Line. Yeah, just get super outrageous.
See and they testified
in front of Congress.
That's why I love this timeline.
It's like this is where we are.
They testified in front of Congress
about Facebook censoring people because
Facebook is censoring them.
They said, what do you see?
What's going on with Alex Jones? If you
right Alex JonesJones' name on Facebook,
it says only you can see this post. I do
license name, I do live streams a lot.
Right. And if the live stream was my
thoughts on Alex Jones live stream,
the second it's uploaded,
it's demonetized and they laid
her has to get remodeled ties.
Once they see it's okay.
So the default setting is,
and that's the other thing of all of
these people. Alex Jones is the worst one.
Like you have actual full blown,
we need another holocaust types
and he's the villain. Yeah,
well he's got a big platform.
That's the idea.
The idea is that he's got a big platform
so they have to show the other lie.
They're like,
oh blah blah blah sandy hook or like
you're an upset when the sandy hook should
happen.
You're getting upset about him now.
Years later.
Cause you're being whipped up into a
froth by the corporate press about it.
You wouldn't flip flip saying
he should be beauty platform.
Seven years ago when was,
whenever it was sandy hook was,
was something around them.
Right. Five years ago.
Well it becomes something that
is a talking point, right? Right.
Like that he needs to be d platform.
Do you use it or agree with
it or you don't agree with it?
And I think that's the case with a
almost what is happening with our, uh,
something happened up there. Oh,
is that the perch? The perch.
Now these guys are here messing
with electronics. Okay. Um, no,
there's no approach here. Yeah.
Okay, good. Yeah, we have security.
I would not do well in purge. Yep.
You're fine. Dude. Stay in this room.
This room was bulletproof.
Yeah. All right. Good to know.
Yeah, you'll be all right,
man. Okay, good. Are you
worried about the purge? No.
Are you worried about the apocalypse? No.
Natural disasters? Not at all. Nothing.
Solar flares taken out
the grid? No. No, no.
I mean there's a satellite's
going wasn't the best books.
No more Sirius satellite radio.
And this is my response to
people on the far right.
And I'm using that term
to term accurately.
It is a great book by Arthur Herman
called the idea of decline in western
history. And he talks about,
you know, every 20 years,
it's a different group on the left,
on the right. And they're like,
the world's going to end.
And he brings the receipts and it never
ends up happening because people are
smart some. And we have a huge
asymmetry in wanting to stay alive.
So the idea that the
last of what apocalypse,
what probably the black plague I would
say would be the last apocalypse we were
doing so good so far. Do you know the
belt, the people that got the black Pitt,
excuse me,
the people that got the black plate
cause they were eaten a Marmot liver,
is that what a,
was it a liver or kill?
I thought they thought it was the fleece
from the rats. No, no, no, no, no.
There's some, oh, recently, recently,
recently got the black plague,
but it's just like the flu now.
The rats,
the last time that happened in the
United States I think was in the 1920s.
And that was in Los Angeles actually. The
last, uh, evidence of the black plague.
Yeah, but you don't die from it anymore.
Oh, you could definitely die from it,
but they died in the twenties I think
they died in the 20s and I thought it's
still okay.
Maybe it's the people died this
year from the black plague. Oh Shit.
People that ate the liver. Okay. Kidney,
I think. Right? You're killing couple,
you know, we're all Marmet kidney. Yeah.
Marmet it's like a vole. Yeah. Yeah.
That's what we used to be
65 million years ago. Yeah.
Just weird little mini museum. Weird
little rodent thing. Yeah. Yeah.
These people hate it. Ate It, and wound up
dying from the play. What was the point?
I had a point about end of the world.
Are we worried about the apocalypse?
You know,
that idea that people have always
worried about the end of the world and it
never happens. Sure. That's like saying,
I've always worried about dying, but
I never have. I'm not going to die.
I'm not going to die. I'm not going
to be there. You're going to die,
but I'm not going to be there.
How do you know? What do you mean?
How do you know you're not
going to be there? But I mean
that's a dying means. Oh,
you not going to be there when you die.
Right? So you're not going to die. Right.
Cause I'm not gonna experience
the hive or you're not.
So don't even worry about
it. Does what? It's over. You
won't be here. So who cares?
I wouldn't say who. So who cares. But I
mean if your entire life is focusing on,
you know, avoiding death, that's a very
bad mindset. Yeah, that's for sure.
That's what I'm saying is that I think
people are operating with a very small
historical timelines and the more I
talk to people like Graham Hancock,
what is the,
describe the overwhelming evidence that
something pretty severe happen to the
human race around 12,800 years ago.
Most likely common impact or some,
something along those lines.
Are there other people think that it was
actually a solar mass coronal ejection
that made lightning storms like rainstorm.
Lightening was coming down like rain
all over the world and just killed
everything.
And this thing could
happen easily at any time.
Not Easily. Oh yeah. Easily. Okay. Yeah.
Common impact or asteroid impact easily,
easily or not easily in terms of
likelihood because it would happen easily.
Turn the likelihood it would've happened
by now. No, no. That has happened.
There's a lot of evidence
that it's happened.
It's just we're dealing with a
small timeline. The ideas could,
could you get lucky and it won't happen
in the next 60 years or so while you're
alive. Yeah. Yeah. Could happen or could
hit tomorrow. That could happen too. Okay.
I'll take that bet. It's good bet. I mean,
it's good. Look, your prospective is good.
That's a good, it's good to not
worry to, to not look at license,
but you don't have power if you don't
have the power to effect the comment as I
personally don't know. That's
true. Uh, knowing it's coming.
Who could theoretically,
what can I do about it?
Just live and I th one of my heroes,
Albert Kamoo, great French philosopher,
you know, his point about living
to the point of tears, right?
And I think what really I find sad in
this culture is cynicism and hopelessness
and it's like we're blessed. You know,
we have this, I mean there's beyond,
beyond the Internet, you can find
people who are making amazing things,
more opportunities than you can count.
And if you're just going
to sit there and Mope,
I mean you're blowing this great gift
that God's given you. Yeah. Well,
I think a lot of those
people that are moping,
that are concentrating entirely
on the negative aspects of life,
they're doing themselves a
giant service and they can't.
It's almost like they can't help it.
I think there's a lot of people that are
affecting the way culture shifts today
that are probably clinically depressed.
And one of the things I resent
enormously about culture is this idea of
something is joyous or fun. It's less,
it's less legitimate artistically.
And that is such a disgusting,
horrible mindset and we need more joy
and more happiness. And I, for me,
because I want to see Jojo
Siwa last night. Okay. Yeah.
Do you know who that is?
You don't know who that is?
She's a youtube star.
My nine year old loves her.
So how to,
how to go to Jojo Siwa was
birthday concert last night. Okay.
At the Microsoft Center.
Whatever the fuck that is.
I know because Burt ran into her at
the airport or loves or two of that bet
because Berta, his young daughters
too. Yeah. She's all about positivity.
Believe and achieve fun times.
I'll upload a video later.
Is it all like Saccharin like Disney
stuff or is it sincere? Sacrad as again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like um, yeah,
she was taking old queen songs and
reworking the words, cleaning them up.
Just like those mean people.
She always, she's cleaning,
she toning down Queen Song
tone down some queen songs. Oh,
this woman is the devil.
How dare you take someone's art and
an appropriate it and make it like a
takeout. All the, all
the energy. Yeah. She uh,
this is corporate culture at its worst,
but she's doing it for three year olds,
Bro. Sell to sleep. Five year olds. They
don't need to be listening to queen over.
There it is. Oh, Jesus Christ loves
Freddy Mercury, Bro. What's problem? No,
she doesn't. If she loved
him, she'd respect him. That's
just fucking 12 she know.
Oh, she's 16 excuse me. Yeah. Should
know any better. She does know better.
How smart were you when you were 16
smart enough not to try to rewrite queen.
I bet she doesn't have a say in it.
I bet whoever's pulling the strings
gets her to rewrite even more nefarious.
Of course the Disney people
or the, the, the, the, the,
the sensors, wherever it is.
The producers. Wait, am I wrong?
Where's the lie? Where's the lie?
What song was it that they did it
to? I'm trying to remember. They did.
We are the champions.
She sang that
the champions. I mean, someone is
a loser. Yeah. No time for losers.
That changed her. No
time. What? Don't got no,
I don't think they've changed that now.
The time for recess.
Oh my God. This is horrifying. Video two,
this is like those videos they made
for like Mormons where they took like
Hollywood blockbusters and cut out
all the sex and all the cursing. Yeah.
And it's like you are evil vampires.
Horrible monsters.
She did crocodile rock. Elton John. Okay.
And she changed Rainbow Chevy to
rainbow beamer. So Crocodile Rock,
you know, my theory is that that
song, I tweeted this out years ago,
I just imagined Elton with a bunch of
his friends all getting high as fuck,
right? And they're like, all right,
let's try to think of the most fucked
up lyric and Eric Elta and you're gonna
make a song about it. They're like,
all right, how about like, um,
like crocodile rock? And he's like,
all right, I'll fucking do it.
And he fucking sits and nails it. And
then what the fuck does that even mean?
What does that mean?
But I'll tell you what man,
the word crocodile means something
different to me after watching that Black
Mirror episode titled Crocodile,
I haven't seen it. Holy Shit.
If you're listening to this,
ladies and gentlemen,
and you have a sensitive heart and you
can't handle really fucked up premises in
a really fucked up episode
like her fans don't want young,
don't watch it cause it's rough.
It's really good though. It's,
but it's like,
Holy Shit.
It's one of those ones where they
are not giving away anything.
But at the end when you're,
when you're done with that show,
you feel like you need a
fucking shower. Like he was
like, whoa. Oh Geez. It's dark.
Okay. There's nothing to do with the
reptiles. I do like dark. It's just dark.
It's dark.
I just read this book by this woman,
Cynthia Carr called fire in the belly.
It's the life story of this artist David,
when he wrote,
which I didn't know anything about and
he was in New York in the early to late
eighties when AIDS was coming up.
And as she tells his life story,
you hear the story of Aids
percolating through this culture.
And that book is as dark as fuck because
she'll have a scene where he's like, oh,
he had dinner and Dah, Dah,
Dah. And the next sentence,
Keith haring died on this day at age 34
and you realize this is what it's like
for them. Like they're hanging
out, phone rings, Keith's dead.
And these are men who are the
symbols of virility early,
late twenties early thirties
just dropping like flies.
And the thing is they're watching
each other die knowing I'm next.
That's going to be me in a year from now.
And they're getting
dementia before they die.
So they're talking all crazy at age 30
so this book really fucked with my head
really, really badly. We're giving them
easy t to yell. Yeah. Didn't help. No,
but that was later.
At first they're like,
we don't know what the fuck
to do is go. Good, good luck.
And it's like we're dying. Like, no, I'm
sorry. Should I suck Dick? It's like,
what the fuck? What the fuck
am I supposed to do? Yeah,
they were calling it the gay cancer.
We didn't know what it was they did.
And then when they were trying to
fight for education, people are like,
well we're not going to teach kids, you
know about sucking Dick. And they're like,
dude, we're dying. And they're
like, mm, sorry about it. And it's,
is this book really got with fucking with
my head especially cause you know it's
real. Yeah. Did you ever hear
a book Kutchers of course,
about chasers both chase fuck
chasers. Yeah. That's again,
we're talking about things that are
just fucked up about human beings.
When you look at the spectrum of behavior,
bug chasers are people who tried, yes.
Gay Men. Right. Cause they thought it was
the ultimate symbol of being gay. Well,
I'm sure there's a bunch of reasons
that was the big reason. Well,
so there was probably that,
but probably they felt bad that other
people had it and they wanted it.
And there was other people that just
wanted it because they're crazy. Sure.
And other people hated themselves.
So they wanted,
there was also that guy
in Germany who was like,
I want to cut off
someone's Dick and eat it.
And they got someone signed up
for it. No, he said, I want to,
I want someone to cut off my dick
and eat it and I want them to eat me.
Right. So someone said, sure, let's meet
up. Yeah, that's right. I got it wrong.
And so the guy cut his dick off and they
both shared his dick and then killed
the dude and started eating them.
And then they arrest him and they didn't
know whether to charge it because it
was voluntary. Yeah, it's
a good point. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't, I'm not a fan, but I
mean you still like you can't,
that's murders. Like it either is
murder or it's not murder. Like if, uh,
if you're in a gay relationship
with the guy and the guy says, okay,
this is what I want you to do,
I want you to beat me up and raped me.
And you're like, oh, okay.
Can I get that in writing?
And you write down and once you to beat
me up and then, you know, the cops come,
he's like, you beat me up. And he
raped me. Like, oh bro, listen here.
He wrote it right here.
He made
a video tape. You didn't use you all
the video and use your safe word.
He said he wanted me to
beat him up and play by him.
And the cops probably let you
go, but you can't murder. Right.
You know what I'm saying? Because
consensual sex is obs obviously legal.
So if you have consensual
sex with someone, it's legal.
But if you pretend to be fighting them
off, right, and then real place you,
it's fun. It's roleplay. But
murders never roleplay. You know,
I found, um, uh, when I was doing research
for the book, the National Review,
who's my favorite paleontology
journal in the late nineties,
as the gay rights movement was coming
up into mainstream consciousness,
they wrote an article comparing the
struggle for gay rights to a struggle for
necrophilia. They're like, love
get a difference. Like if I,
and they talked about how right now in
the European Union perverts are fighting
for the right to be violent toward
each other in bed in, in various ways.
It's like, yeah, it's like rough sex. It's
adjacent to vanilla sex. They like it.
And now the are the articles are the
conservative case for gay marriage.
It's like you guys have no fucking shame
then and you have no fucking shame now
at least be consistent.
One of the things that disturbs me
greatly today is there is a movement,
and I don't know how big it is,
but it's a movement for people
to try to recognize pedophiles,
us as a sexual distinction,
as sexual designation rather than a sick
disease that similar to being trans or
being gay or that some people
are just born pedophiles. Well,
I think what's important there is it's
not just a crime because a crime can be
fixed and treated.
So I think it is important to
understand these people will always
psychologically be pedophiles and
you're not going to get them to be like,
Whoa, uh, straight, you know, hold on.
No therapy that's ever been
shown that I think it's,
I try and make someone who's gay.
It's straight. Is it really that,
that's my understanding.
If that's the case,
then is there an argument that we should
be more compassionate with them as long
as they don't act on that. But that's
the danger. Because the other thing,
what they don't understand
is from their point of view,
those kids are giving consent, which
they are, right? The kids saying yes.
So they're like, look man,
that's what's scary. I don't
even know if they do. Right.
They don't think a statutory raping
a thing. And I knew, okay, this,
I interned at a place long ago and there
was a librarian who worked there like a
Guido type,
you know,
and grow or Guy Guy and
years later he was arrested.
He was a schoolteacher.
He was arrested at an undercover sting
trying to meet a kid who he knew was 13
or 12 in a park to try to sleep with him.
Right.
This was an Jeanine Pirro who
later became a Fox commentator.
He got out of jail and
I see him on Facebook,
he's married with kids and it's just like,
you think it's fine that that
shit scary shit. That's insane.
And it's thing to be switched gender too.
If you're going for young boys,
you're going to go to like regular aged
women. I don't see how that would work.
Right,
right.
And this is something that is such a
taboo topic that I don't think once you,
for a lot of people correctly, once you
start talking about kids in sexuality,
their hackles res,
it is a PC subject.
Cause it's like why even introducing
this into the conversation where you're
going with this, it's a very,
very, very slippery slope. Well,
if you're trying to say or if they're
trying to say that this is something that
people are born with,
I don't think there's evidence
that people just are born that way.
I think there's evidence that people
become that way from sexual abuse. Yes,
that's true too. Absolutely.
And they think it's appropriate.
Never heard of anybody that grew up
in a normal household wasn't abused.
Is that the case? I might not in a
position to talk about this at all.
I think we have probably a very few
cases of pedophiles on the record, uh,
explaining how they came to
this point of view. But he,
in either situation born or abuse,
I can't see how this is something that's
going to be, uh, an emotion level.
You're going to be able to turn
them away. Well, it's also a super,
the idea of that being in
your neighborhood. Yes. This
is in your neighborhood.
You've got this guy who likes to fuck
kids and he promises not to do it anymore,
but they did a few times.
They locked him up in a cage.
Now he lived down the street and he
locked up on a couch where he was
traumatized. Also further traumatized,
so and also if he promised not to do it,
but knowing when he's looking at it,
he's checking out my son or my daughter.
Yeah. I did not accept to be talking
about this today. I know. Of course.
That's just the beauty of the show.
It's a fucking the,
that the human mind can be that it'd
be imprinted in your abused when you're
younger, that you go on to do that same
thing that was horrifically done to you,
that that is a common thing that happens
with children that may get abused,
doesn't make sense to you. It does make
sense to me. It's like that way I'm not,
I wasn't abused. I was enjoying
it. Could be. Right. You know,
that that way it takes away
the trauma cause it's like,
oh this is how I've always been.
So it was okay,
nothing happened to me and you don't
have to deal with the trauma that way.
Well that's what my low and when he was
talking about being sexually abused as a
child. Right. I think that's what
he was kind of doing. Oh yeah,
he was saying I was the Predator and
I w I was going on for the panel.
Talk about that in the book because if
there was anyone other than Milo people
would, because he was older, he
wasn't like 12 he was like whatever,
1814 I think he was like,
I don't remember how well do
you know if he's 18 is fine.
It wasn't 18 but it wasn't 12 I think
he was a teenager. But if you're young,
if it was somebody else, people are we
talking about heteronormativity. Right.
And it's historically not that weird for
an older gay dude to get with a younger
gay guy, especially when everyone was
closeted to kind of initiate them into the
lifestyle. This was a thing, but
it's my low now it's, Oh my God,
you want pedophilia,
blah blah.
It's like there's different standards
for gay people that frustrate people and
that's appropriate and acceptable and
people understand that in other contexts.
Well the problem is society as
the way we understand human beings
and the way a person's brain
works when you're young,
you shouldn't be allowed to make those
decisions because sexually in particular
you could get coerced.
You can. Yes you can get,
you can wind up doing something
that you don't want to do,
that can be straight guys that are 14
years old and her talked into having gay
sex by a very charismatic 40 year
old man who gives them things.
The idea is that this is
a bad thing for the boy.
It's bad thing cause you wouldn't
want to happen to a girl.
Why would you want to happen to a boy?
But I think it's a very
different phenomenon for a
30 year old man to sleep with
a 30 year old gay man to sleep
with a 16 year old gay man.
As far as 30 year old boy.
Sure.
As opposed to 30 year old gay straight
man to sleep with a 16 year old straight
girl. I think you can make that argument
that it is a little bit different.
I still don't think it's okay.
I'm not saying it's okay.
I'm just saying clearly it's different.
It's different and yeah,
especially if the boy is like very gay,
very obviously gay,
which you know everyone or high school,
remember it's not a virgin. Right.
That true to that first,
that first guy for that girl will
fuck with her head for her life.
For many women. For him it could
be, it wasn't his first. Yup.
That's a very big difference too. Yeah.
Yeah. You don't want to be that first guy.
That's a lot of work.
I don't even mean with gay.
I mean it was straight to, I don't
think I ever had a virgin of my life.
I've never had a virgin. Thank God
so much work. I say I connected.
You'd be like forever basically
be too much work. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I mean, yeah, I should probably clarify.
I mean being connected to the upper,
it's too significant.
You want to be like the third guy.
You don't want to be the
first car girl has sex with.
You were always my first Michael.
I'll never forget,
I always thought that we were supposed
to be together forever and never,
because I believe in movies
and fairy tales that you were,
and I listened to the Queen Songs
with a nice lyrics to work chooses.
He was concert cheeks, plane,
everything is like a movie. Yeah.
You uh, yeah. That's a thing, right?
Like people do get emotionally attached
to romantic stories that they see in
movies and they want their life to
play out like this fictional narrative.
And the left uses this a lot because
they'll have all these leftist ideas in
culture and movies and that's where a
lot of people get their programming. Uh,
and then it's like, you know, for example,
here's an idea you don't see in culture
that people very often knowingly and
consciously do the wrong thing.
And that happens every day.
People know they're doing
something fucked up.
You don't really see that that much in
like TV and movies and that's a right
wing message that like, you know,
people sometimes are basically evil. Um,
and you can run into someone at that
point in their life, they're evil.
That's a fact. And I'm sure that exists
all over the world. Or like it, I, I,
it's also evil on a small scale.
Like if you're in an office and someone's
getting chewed out and they're getting
bullied for whatever reason,
and you're sitting there and
you're keeping your mouth
shut, you're not Hitler,
but you know, you're doing
the wrong thing, but you're
trying to protect your job,
right?
Sure.
The boss to come down on you let a lot
of times that you have that space and you
still won't do it. And that's
knowingly doing the wrong thing.
And I'm not saying you should
be thrown in the garbage,
but I'm saying people
do that all the time.
These little sacrifices they make with
their conscience. That's true. Yeah.
And you don't see that really represented.
And that's an important idea for people
to understand that people are often weak.
Yeah. And always, especially
if you're going check to
check. Always worried. Yeah.
Losing your job. Losing your Gig. Yeah.
That's a real big thing with people till
I was on vacation once and there's this
guy who's a boss and he was there
with his employees, employees,
family and he was mean to his
employees daughter are to watch it.
The guy had to take it. He's just
talking shit. He to her and it was just,
it was really gross cause you
can see the dynamic play out.
He was just this mean old guy,
just really shitty.
It was disturbing to see this week man,
like just having to accept the fact that
this guy is my shitty to his daughter
and he was giving her a
lecture and berating her and
doing it publicly like are
the poem God? Is this who you want it
to grow up to be? Is this job worth it?
It was so gross. I W I wanted
to step in. I was like,
I just want to tell this guy to shut
the fuck up. It's driving me nuts.
I remember when I was back before
I started me out being an author,
I was working at Goldman and it
was a very stressful job and they,
I had my review and
they said, oh, you know,
if you have downtime sometimes
we see like going online,
we want you to help the laptop lab.
And I just go, no. And she goes, what?
I said I wasn't hired to do laptops. I'm
not interested in, in learning laptops.
And there are,
the job is very intense and high stress.
So if I have downtime I'm going
to, you know, use the downtime.
And the look on her face was just like
as if I just added myself as a pedophile.
What did it mean by use the law? I
was doing laptop, the laptop lab,
I was doing tech support.
So like Microsoft word,
Excel. People had problems.
They would call on the fly. You've got
to have an answer for them. It's very,
it's like a quiz show. You're living in
quiz show and then there's a laptop lab.
People are checking out laptops,
they're setting up laptops,
which is a very different skillset.
Something I didn't really know.
Setting up in terms of like
downloading. Sure. Yeah. I,
you know like where and I didn't know
then I still don't know. I didn't,
I don't fuck with you. Like, no,
it's not my job now I'm not and I'm
not interested in working as hard as
possible.
While also like when you have downtime
with did they want you to work extra it,
the point is the phone rings or it
doesn't ring. Right. It's your job.
That's my job.
My job's to get off the phone as fast as
possible because their problem solved.
So there what they were saying was
while you were doing this other job and
waiting for something to come up,
we want you to keep you working
specifically different jobs. Correct.
Yeah. No, it's corporations, man.
That's right. Squeeze that rock. Right.
And it's like,
why am I busting my ass to make
Goldman Sachs that extra $5 of value?
Fuck you.
And I'm so proud of myself that far.
You after that they fired me because I
refused to work in Thanksgiving because
my great grandma had died. So I wanted
you to work on thanksgiving. We were 24,
seven but we're 24. It's a,
it's a help desk. Oh Wow.
But you must've shifts. I was second
shift, 4:00 PM to midnight, right?
Every night. Monday through
Thursday or Friday. Monday,
Thursday. Okay. And they go,
oh, we're having you in on, um, Thursday
during the day, Thanksgiving Day.
And I'd promised my and
I work second shift.
So they wanted me four to midnight
then in there at nine. And I said, no,
I promised my grandma I'd have
Thanksgiving dinner with lunch with her.
I could've called my
grandmother's schedule.
I didn't want to be that guy cause I
knew this was one of those, you know,
things that like, this is the fork road,
a crossroads in your life. And they go,
we'll find someone else to
cover your shift. And I asked,
everyone else had plans and they go,
well we need you midnight, you know,
the second next day for
lunch. And I said, no.
And they fired me. And I'm
very, very glad I did that.
And I had lunch with grandma.
Her mom had just died or they allowed
to fire you for that if it's not your
shift. Yeah, of course they
are. Of course. Well, no,
the shift every week they would get the
calendar, right. So this week, right? Oh,
I see. So you wasn't, you didn't
have a specific shift came Michael,
every day you come in at eight o'clock,
I usually did.
Or forklift when you had holidays,
things had to change. And I'm like, well,
I don't care. And I, and no
regrets. Well worked out. It did.
But did you ever think that you'd
be like this? Uh, what are you,
what do you opened it? I'm a, I'm a,
what am I an author? Media personality,
I think is the word central
though. Immediately I went
right to it about myself.
I saw that you wanted to be a troll.
Like first thing you think on it is like
if someone says like, what do you do?
You like trouble. Ah, I'm an author now
what? Actually, you know what I say? Uh,
when people ask me what I do,
I say, you know, those, uh,
obnoxious people who have a job giving,
they're uninformed opinion. That's me.
That's what I usually say. Interesting.
Yeah. Isn't that funny that that's a job.
All you have to do is be
kind of entertaining and
have an interesting way of
looking at things.
It's great that this is what I'm talking
about being blessed and I don't take it
for granted and the fact that like people
pay my rent because of my sick burns
on Twitter. Unpatriotic Burn,
burn. I love my sick birds.
And you used to be a Microsoft help
representative for Goldman Sachs wanted?
Yeah. Was it Microsoft? Just
Microsoft or at, yeah, all
the Microsoft products. Yeah.
Yeah. Do you use windows? I do. Do you?
Yeah. You don't use apple? I don't,
I you seem like a guy.
You seem like I use an android phone too.
I haven't enjoyed filling. Ah, I
do a little bit of a contrarian.
I have a little bit,
yeah. Do you like windows?
Because the people that use macs are
just like following the sheep herd.
I use windows because that's
what I was professional on,
so I haven't changed in all this time.
The only thing that bugs me about windows,
I have to constantly be updating.
You turn that shit off.
You have to turn that shit off.
Why? Because on the uptake,
sometimes it's crashed my computer. Oh,
when it updates, so I'm not rolling.
That fear of the computer, we start.
How often do you update your software?
But what if they fixed like vulnerability?
They're going to invent new words.
It's fine. It's fine if they get the
squiggly line. When I write the word meme,
why would I worry about is like
vulnerabilities to the system.
I have everything backed up in three
places. Oh, I'm a crazy person like that.
Okay, so you're ready to rock
and do you run some run a VPN?
No. No. Ooh. Then I'm, and I'm
piloting that shit too. I would you,
I would you say that on there?
I'll shit, they're gonna.
I think I'm going to get swatted down and
get you gotta get Swat. A real pirate.
They're gonna fucking [inaudible]
me and Madonna with the eyepatch.
Madonna has an iPod. Yeah. You
didn't see that thing. See,
I think it's a fashion thing, but
it could be a glaucoma thing. One
just got an eyepatch. Mm. Yeah.
Maybe she's just a fan of slick Rick.
Do you know who's you know my favorite
comedian? You'll hamburger. Yeah, sure.
I love Neil. He's my absolute favorite
comedian. And one of his jokes is,
what do you call a senior citizen who
can't help but expose their genitalia in
public?
But Donna,
and he says it all sad.
Oh,
he's got such a weird act. He's so
funny. Oh, he's the best. It's a strange,
strange act. Well, he's just basically
like Tony Clifton. Yeah. As as a stand up,
but better but better material. Much
better material. Better presentation.
I talk about Kauffman in the book
because he's the first troll.
[inaudible] Andy Kaufman was
the first chore. Yeah, I agree.
And there's this great, he
had this character, Tony
Clifton. People don't know.
He's just like angry lounge singer. And
Tony did this bid. He would perform,
I think it was in Atlantic city.
And he said, hey, my wife died.
Whenever I look at my daughters, you
know Stephanie's eyes, I see her.
So that's seven and come out
and do a song, sits on his lap,
they sing her voice cracks, he
smacks her across the face. He goes,
are you fucking it up? The audience
is booing and goes, don't blow it.
You just got to make her cry more. And
it wasn't even a kid. It's an actress.
You know what I mean? Quarterly. That
is just beautiful. Trolling. Yeah.
Well he used to cough means to go on stage
and sing the mighty mouse theme song,
but just the mightiness part. Yeah,
you, you're welcome to save the day.
He did the special, and I think it
was ABC, refuse to air for two years.
And one of the parts, it was like
peewee's playhouse, where piece piece,
play a house. He had a girl from
sound of music and she's like, oh,
she's starting to, you know,
restart a career. He called.
It has been quarter and she comes out.
He goes,
so at what point did you realize you
weren't gonna make it and show this, this,
it's just, she's in on it,
you know, but it's just,
you're sitting there, you're like,
oh my God. Even if you're in on it,
it's kind of staying. And she's like, Oh,
real, I'm trying to restart my career.
He goes, well, I don't think it's
going to happen for you, but good luck.
And you're just like, oh my God. Well,
how about when he was wrestling women?
That was this thick of sexual
thing, but yeah, I'm sure. Yeah,
but it was also trolling, isn't it? Yeah,
yeah. Yeah. Was screaming and yelling
and I know that part, but
yeah. Yeah. But I did that.
I'm not a fan of the fucking
people at the wrestling arenas.
They wanted to kill him. Yeah.
They wanted to fucking kill him.
They thought it was real. I got Dolph
Ziggler coming up on my show tomorrow. Um,
and he's like,
he come,
came out once dressed as the
undertaker and the audience,
what he pulls off the head
where like bullying goes. Oh,
you thought it was really good about him.
You only see once a year,
so he fucking comes dressed this other
wrestlers just to troll the audience.
I love that shit. Well, when you got to
think also when coffin was doing this,
there was real discussion as to whether
or not wrestling was real. Yeah.
This is a different
time. Yeah. It's amazing.
You can look back at these arguments
that people are like, oh yeah, yeah,
it's totally fucking real. He was
taken. Do you know? It's really though,
what's fascinating though, because
with the rise of the MMA, yeah,
I just saw like the WWE
admass square garden.
We know what the dynamics of
fighting it looks like. Right? Right.
But the wrestlers,
it's still the same motions.
It's like we know that if you hit someone
here how they actually react because
we've seen it thousands of times for real,
but you guys are still like if
someone punches you in the neck,
you're not going to be
passed out on the floor.
Will also somewhere else who's got upset
because I was explaining that a figure
four leg lock doesn't work.
Not only does it not work,
but you're setting yourself
up for, he'll hook. Okay. I'm
like, let me explain. Yeah,
and they were mad like how dare
you disrespect for wrestling. What?
It's also like if you close
slides, someone that's going
to hurt you. No, no, no.
That's not true.
If someone 200 pounds hits me here,
it's not going to hurt my
shoulder. No, no, looks fine. Okay,
then not know what the fuck
I'm talking about this issue.
I'll fuck you up with a clothes
line. How that's like, dude,
you just hitting someone in
the head with your forearm.
You could fuck somebody able to close
on really a hundred percent in the neck
one, but it's not going to hurt.
You know? I mean mine. Okay.
You haven't taught you punched. Somebody
could break your I'm sure, but no.
Are you close on someone? That
shit's totally legit. Okay,
let me that people get code from that
all the time. It's like a, like a leg.
Like if you kick someone in the neck,
right? Like if someone gets net kicked,
they go out. Sure. You could do that
with your arm. Same thing. Same motion.
Your Shin is stronger for
sure than your forearm,
but especially this way. See,
there's two bones, right?
There's the owner and what's the Tibia?
Fibia? No, that's your leg. Okay.
I don't know. Tibias I
broke the fibula. The, the,
the smaller one or the Tibia.
Which one? I broke the little one.
Which one's the Big One? Which one's
your Shin? Your tea. Your femurs.
The top. And then I left Fibula.
I think it's the fibula. I broke.
I broke the one. What's that? Tibi is the
bigger one. Yeah, I broke the smaller one.
Okay.
It's fucking gross.
It was really painful and they
couldn't do anything about it. It just,
it was just a hairline fracture. Oh, see
that guy just close line by this dude.
Boom. Okay. Wow. But the cop
doesn't know how to land it. Look,
you went down with it too.
He probably broke his fucking arm.
That's how you fuck that
up top. Broke his arm. See,
it's barely using his arm.
Oh, it definitely works out.
Okay. Yeah, like in the UFC.
Well, the thing is like my point was
I think the big, where's the big bone?
Where's the little bone? I think in
the front this happens all the time.
Guys get kicked in.
This bone breaks,
well actually sometimes
both of the bones break,
but it with a spinning back fist when
they're landing at a lot of times they're
landing it with their,
with their forearm,
what not landing it with the actual fist.
What about Randy Savage?
If you're jumping out the top row on
your elbow when you break your elbow or
kill the person,
if you're landing on his neck,
you will hurt him for sure and
you're slamming down the elbow.
It's definitely got more force,
but when you're getting on top of
someone and you're smashing with elbows,
which you can do an MMA, you can
generate incredible amounts of forest.
If you ever watch a guy work out on the
heavy bag where the heavy bags on the
ground, they worked the ground
and pound, just boom, boom.
I mean you think about that being your
fucking head. It's incorrect, but,
and if you're 200 pounds to 50
jumping off a rope on an elbow,
it's a small point. I would think that
would, I mean, break something in there.
It could, it could just really
hitting him though. He's, yeah,
he doesn't hit him chest, but if that were
for real, but just that, first of all,
the reality is just that alone.
I mean,
even though he only liked bounces
off of them a little bit. Yeah, he's,
he's just got it down where
he lands first with the feet.
If you watch the impact, if you
slow down the feet, land first,
and then he's absorbing all
of it and just, he lands the,
the, the side of his body on the guy's
chest, but it's a secondary impact.
Boom. See? Oh he collapses
to, it's like a one,
two and he doesn't hit him that hard,
but he hits him hard enough that it sucks.
Like it ain't fun to be around, so it's
a tough gig. But that shit would work.
Clothes lining, someone would
work. It's just not ideal.
The ideal thing to do for someone's,
it's just palm them in the face.
If you get close lie on, you could also
just pop them in the face. That's that.
The good thing about the palm and
the face is that first of all,
it's extremely difficult to
break your palm like this.
Think about what you can do.
Okay,
this is the Oak table and I'm slamming
my hand into it. I have no pain at all.
You can't do that with any other part of
your body. You can't kick it like that.
If with your Shin, you know you can't
punch it like that with your knuckles.
Even your elbow or kind of hurts
more than your palm. The Palm,
you can really fucking smack
the funny bone to. Yes. Yeah,
but you could fuck somebody up
on an elbow and though sure,
like in Moitai it's one of the eight
points of contact, but a palm strike.
If someone's charging at you,
just smack him.
You could have a tremendous impact on
your hand and still get away with it and
knock someone out. John Hackleman who
is a chuck Liddell's former trainer,
trainer of um, um, I
actually current trainer for,
he still works out trainer
Glover to sharer just one
of the best guys in MMA. He,
uh,
has these little videos on his Instagram,
I think it's the pit or
pit master pitmaster on
Instagram talking about street
self defense things and he's
always advocating hitting
people with your palm so
people break their hands, all the
tonic. Isn't that the whole thing?
He hit him in the nose to kind of,
that's not real. That's not real.
The idea of drive the bone up,
you'll break their nose.
Not that you're gonna kill them,
but like that's the easiest self defense
anywhere. Even the side of the head.
But the idea is hitting
them with the palm.
I thought you were going to say
when I said that's not real.
There was one where kids, it
was like a, in a karate movie,
the guy would hit the palm up to the nose.
The nose bone would go into the brain.
It would kill some ones that
happened in like a Seagal movie.
Smash him in the nose.
I thought you were gonna say that,
but the idea is that you could
just without worry of consequences,
you could palm strike someone in the face
like really hard and never break your
hand.
A regular person throwing a punch,
you have a real good chance of breaking
your hand. Okay. Real good chance.
Like if you crack someone in the forehead,
most likely you're gonna break your
hand or your wrist or something else.
But with your palms you can
just fucking waylay somebody.
You could smack the shit out of somebody,
but you're going to look kind of silly.
There was, uh, an organization,
the MMA more organization back in
the early days called pancreas.
I think he might be still around,
but they have modified rules.
But pancreas back in the day they were
wrestling shoes with Shin pads and they
wore like little tiny little speedos and
they would smack each other with their
hands so they'd kick and punch
and do submission techniques.
It was fairly crude in
comparison to today's MMA. Sure.
But we got to see a lot of leg
locks back then. And there was,
there was some fishy fights too.
But my point is like boss route and was
the first guy figured out how to really
fuck people up with palm strikes.
And what he did is he has
a really flexible wrists
and he's a bad ass striker.
So he learned how to pull his hands way
back and he would just throw them like
punches. He would just do the same
motions that he would do with a punch,
but just smash guides with his,
with his palms.
And he was lighting people up like a
Christmas tree in Pancrase with that
horrific to what he fucked. He came out
a bunch of people with his palms. Huh?
See if you've watched boss Rutan Kao
put put boss route and Kaos Funai he
catered food [inaudible] who is a like
an elite MMA fighter who was a Hixon
Gracie's last opponent and
Hickson was fighting MMA.
But for Nakia I think started out in
pancreas and boss route and code them.
And the way K Odom was like,
like like a punch,
but he was doing it with his palms,
just smashing people.
So it's like your hand,
like there's a lot of things that you
think wouldn't work. Clothes lines,
one of them. That shit would work. Okay.
That's my point. Not The hockey talk.
Bands move though.
What's the a hundred on a shake?
Rattle and roll and it just
flips him on his back. It's like,
why does this even hurt?
You don't remember this.
You didn't watch wrestling in the
eighties no. Well, how about the DDT here?
So here's bacilli that knee, but the
knee, you have a backup before that.
Back Up. Before that. Here, watch.
Watch how he's hitting him. He's so,
he's using like a boss was a fucking
gorilla back. They look the size of them.
See smacking shit out of him.
He's using his head.
She always hitting him
with his [inaudible]. He's
thrown them like punches.
But this knee is what did it.
Boom. Yeah. Boss was a beast, man.
He was a fucking beast.
He was probably the first really elite
striker that we saw an MMA where you're
like, whoa, like this is what can happen.
Like when he was kicking people in
Pancrase, everybody was like, whoa.
Like this is this guy can fucking kick.
Like you're seeing a lot of guys who are
kicking that were kind of like karate
bay. Maybe they didn't have as much power,
but boss was, he was a Dutch kickbox.
He was smashing people.
Boom. He looks scary.
He was a bad motherfucker.
Bad motherfucker. He won
the UFC heavyweight title.
He was the first guy ever,
I think in my recollection to win
a title off of his back by uh,
from strikes. He fought Kevin Random
and Kevin ran him as a badass wrestler,
kept taking them down and boss was beating
the shit out of him from the bottom,
throwing elbows and,
and they gave him a decision,
which a lot of people disagreed
with. But I was like, man,
you look at the volume of strikes
landed then way more you, you just,
just being on top side.
Good enough.
You have to actually do something
with the position. Huh? Okay.
This is not a subject expert road.
Yeah, yeah. Hey, yeah, this is,
this is the old school, but you got to
really look at whole body kick. Fuck,
fuck people up, man. Boss.
Ruin was no joke, man. Dude,
he was fucking people up. They had,
nobody had seen anything like that. This,
those guys just couldn't strike like that.
They didn't have that kind of power.
You'd see the impact, but then, you know,
like all things, it caught up. Yeah.
Oh good Lord. The USC, then they got, um,
there was some elite fighters to start
showing up in the UFC or Lando Veit
smashing machine. Mark. Mark. Yeah. Well
he was different man. He was a wrestler.
He was a wrestler slash science project.
Like, yeah, he was used up real good.
God, that's to put it mildly. Yeah.
There's a great documentary on the special
machine. You saw it. Yeah. It's amazing.
It caught him. They, they
were that documentary,
the purpose of it was initially to
catch him as the scariest fighter on the
planet. This guy who was just this Goliath
who just dominating people in Japan,
but in the process of documenting
it, he was falling apart. That's him.
When he was his biggest, he would say
his, his neck would start at his ears
and he was very skillful as well.
I mean just really gives all
American wrestler before that, right?
The elite wrestler and um,
just,
just gigantically that upper left hand
picture. Upper left. Look at that one.
Same One. Yeah, but click on that. That's
the one I started with. No, why is it? No,
that's different. It's very different.
The same photo. No, it's not.
It's just different effects.
Photo. Yeah, but look at them.
But that one looks like shit.
Go to the other one again.
That's a different version of it.
Look at that fucking Jesus Christ.
That is insane. The fact that a
person could get to look like that.
That is insane. There's guys
that look like that at my gym.
Fuck you all at Harvard fitness are
listening to this show in the locker room
while my scrawny ass is right there.
And you don't even notice me.
You wonder like what? It's like
walking around looking like that. Well,
you can find out if you took all those
same steroids, but they're also like six,
you know? Yeah. You would do a
mini version of that. Yeah. Yeah.
We're likely priests. Yeah.
Do you lift weights? Yeah.
What kind of Shit do you do?
I have a split, uh, six days
a week. Do you have a trainer?
A yeah. Oh, look at you like a wolf.
You try shout out to Michael Wolf. Yeah,
he's like a deadlift guy.
Yeah, he's a dead lift.
But it's also important for
me psychologically and for
people who are depressed
or anxious. Uh, I've sometimes
have a lot of downtime.
So if I go to the gym,
I can tell my brain I'm objective Lee,
a better person than yesterday
and I did something today.
So it really helps with
keeping you mentally grounded.
I'm never going to get jacked, but
I could see, I learned this from um,
Matt Hughes now. He was the first
one to take me to Jim. Really? Yeah.
Matthew first want to take you to a author
author's book and I realized I don't
have to look like Mark Kerr. I could still
look like a better version of me. Yes.
And when you have that realization,
it's, it's very liberating.
The mental health benefits and
people need to realize that.
And the thing is other people who are
like, really, like the first day I went,
I was all nervous and I know what I'm
doing and there was a guy I wish I could
thank him. He's like, are you done with
this machine? And I'm like, yeah. He goes,
thanks brother. I'm like, all
right. No one hears judging you.
Everyone's doing their own shit
and if you're, if you're happy,
you're working out and if you're fat,
everyone's cheering you on. Yeah, yeah.
They were like, fuck yeah. You're
getting good for, you know,
the opposite of what people would
think. Yeah. So no one cares.
Uh, it's, I really recommend it. Yeah.
There's a lot of gyms have
a good culture of support,
a good culture of encouragement.
You know,
like this is the reason why a lot of
people that are on Instagram are fitness
people that are also motivational. Yeah.
This is the culture of these communities.
Like when you see people doing reps, like,
come on, come on. You got it. You got it.
You got it. Like that sort of
support. Is it, there's something too,
there's endorphins that get released when
you're all pushing each other together.
I mean this one of the big rushes of
martial arts training is that you're,
you're pushing each other,
you work out together and
then afterwards over you just,
everything seems to be more normal and
I seems more rational and I have people
follow me on Twitter, Insta, like Jack
paypal and they give me advice and,
and they're very supportive
that, yes, and that's the thing,
that's the real big misconception
I guess from those movies.
The sales of Rent Rom,
Rom coms will tell you that the guy who's
like a big guy's a bully and sometimes
he is, but most of the people who
were like serious about fitness,
they want other people to be like, come
on this, this'll be great for you. Yeah.
I think most people's experience
with bullies is really
high school stuff, right?
It's like jocks in high school and lot
of them are just, as we were saying,
insecure and a lot of
them are also probably,
it's probably their experience
experiencing at home from their dads.
And I think that's changed a lot
because thanks to the Internet now.
I think the jocks respect
the nerds a lot more.
When I was working with Hughes
and I met all those fighters,
they could not be friendlier or more like,
Hey, you're, you're doing your thing.
I do my thing. I can relate to that.
That's awesome. So there was no,
uh, I'll look at this pussy or
whatever like that, you know. Well,
fighters are a lot nicer
than people think, but there,
cause they're so disciplined
is that for sure.
And they know what it's like to get their
ass kicked. And it's humbling muscle.
Jamo who's a famous, a karate guy, he, uh,
he said it's not that fighters are any
nicer, is kind of Tika. He was calling it,
you know,
karate practitioners were any nicer.
It's just they're tired from training.
He might be right, but they,
they do behave nicer because
of that. It's, it's both.
But I think it's also one of the things
I love about the Internet is that if
you're doing your thing now,
people respect someone else's doing their
own weird thing as opposed to when we
were kids, there'd be that one
Weirdo. Like I had this tweet.
There's two types of people, right? If
you learn someone is a Guinea pig breeder,
there's two approaches. You're weird.
What the Fuck's wrong with you?
Or sit down and tell me
everything and I'm very much,
and people who follow me are the second
one. It's like you're doing your thing.
It's gives you joy and passion.
I've never heard of it. Let me know.
I want to know too that I watched an
episode of Anthony Bourdain's old show was
called no reservations and he was in,
I forget what country it was,
but these people bread Guinea pigs for
food. Oh yeah. Sounds like Erica cabbies.
Yeah.
They had Guinea pigs running around the
house or they were all over the place.
Yeah. And then when they wanted to
cook something, they reached down,
grabbed Guinea pig,
just picked it up and killed it,
cooked it all the other kidney
pigs and you fucking know. Oh yeah.
They said domestic. They're nearly
dumb, but they don't, it's, it's,
it's a good argument for eating Guinea
pigs so they don't seem to miss their
friend. I just got, uh, someone just
paypaled me a contribution. 300 bucks,
Adam. And he says, go out to dinner or
buy something stupid. Probably Guinea pig.
Hold on. Not Better. If someone says this
is for stupid things. I'm like, all right.
It's an ardor. It's your money. So I
bought some stupid things. You some money
I got, I got this. And I'm
like, elephant is unethical.
Mm. There's, they recognize themselves
and mirror, they have a social structure.
This is draft. It's stupid. I got draft
a leather wallet. Let me see that.
There you go. Wow. But it's nice and
it's stupid. Wraps are so nice. They're,
they're dumb. They're like cows or that's
dumb. They're just dumb. They're dumb.
They're dumb. Are you sure? I'm
positive to run some tests on.
My friend owns my friend's parents,
each own a zoo and I've gone,
I've gone with him to different zoos.
Drafts are very dumb,
but they're so peaceful that they
let little kids feed them at the zoo.
That's one of the only animals where
they let people feed them. That's true.
And they just reach out with their tongue.
Like I'll never forget that my daughter
was like to take it into the zoo and her
giggling and laughing.
When the naysayers,
the big crazy tongue comes
out and grabs the lettuce,
they can clean their ears with their
tongue boob. Yeah. Um, I would,
that was a joke that I used to have
about how they are the only animal that I
could point to.
That's a wild animal that doesn't seem
to have any problem with domestication.
Yeah.
When they're at the zoo,
that like another day with no
lions and just strolling around.
Did you ever say that to eat though that
blue planet where the lines are trying
to kill the giraffe and the desert and
she's just kicking him in the face? Dude.
Shit, they kick them and
break their fucking jaws.
It's really dangerous for lions when they
fuck with zebras or eat your ass drab
zebras as well. But whenever they
fuck with any animal with hubs,
that's probably one of the
reasons why they have hooves.
Yeah. It's like a weapon.
Same like they have antlers.
I mean it certainly helps them traverse
difficult terrain and helps them run,
protects her feet.
Where do you,
where do you draw the line when it comes
to like leather or different animals?
It's a good question. Yeah. Um, I,
I've gotten very, very interested
in elephants, you know,
in terms of like their social structure
and what they're like and learning about
how intelligent they are and
how long their memory is.
And I don't want to have anything to do
with elephant leather or ivory prebate a
queue a long time ago that
had a elephant ear as a wrap.
Okay. And I didn't think anything
of it, but now I think, yeah, I, I,
that's my line. I like, they have
elephant wallets and I was like, no,
I'm not comfortable with this. Here's the
thing, man. Pigs are super fucking smart.
Pigs are real sweet.
And when you domesticate them,
like people have domesticated
pigs that as they're well fed,
they behave a lot like dogs.
The only difference being of
course if you fall in the pig pen,
they will fucking eat you. Yeah. And
they had to often, that happened.
That's a very common
way for farmers to die.
They fall in the pig pen in the file, like
scraps at clothes and like, oh my God,
I'm just a puddle of blood. My
Buddy, the fuck is left there. Yeah.
So I know now, thankfully they're coming
out with this kind of synthetic food,
synthetic amaze people know
that mimics pork or chicken. Oh,
mimicking it's actual chicken cells
or pork cells or whatever. Yes. Yes.
And that's going to be a great
day. Yeah. That brings me the,
the beyond burger that people keep.
It googled this cause I want to make
sure this is true because someone sent me
this, I didn't have the time
to check, uh, beyond meat, uh,
test positive for glyphosate,
glyphosate.
Glyphosate is roundup masonic hall.
It's very fucking dangerous
that trying to pretend it's not.
But meanwhile the addition out
fucking lawsuits when one couple got,
was it $2 billion,
they got a $2 billion ruling
against Monsanto and another
guy got 5 million to 2
billion cause they got cancer being
pesticides. I'm like, yeah, give me the,
I'll drink this shit.
I've got a good lawyers were big,
they're probably going to lose. And I
mean that seems like a lot of money. Yeah,
of course. Um, but I was reading
that uh, that, you know, fits a,
it's a meat based in a non meat based
Burger that's supposed to taste pretty
similar to me.
I haven't had one yet,
but what I'm saying is now they
figured out how to take yeah.
Sales and replicate that it actually is
meat. No. Right. No animals being killed.
Right. Which is the ideal. I just wonder
if there's any, it's dangerous for you,
but this glyphosate thing,
I need to find out if this is correct.
That's the only reason why I
brought it up. I just remembered.
And I think it's important
for people to have,
this is one of the best things about
that whole kind of a Paleo whole foods
situation of no way. If you're going to
act in a certain way towards your food,
know what you're doing and be happy
to draw that line about, okay,
what are you comfortable with and
defend your decision. Yeah. Yeah. What,
what are you willing to kill? You know,
uh, my friend Chris Pratt? Hell yes. Um,
he's got a farm,
he's got his own thing that he does
and he takes lamb and you know,
he,
he puts the rod on their head and yeah,
and puts him to sleep and they have
no idea what's going to happen.
And then they just die instantly.
And he made this like really detailed
post on Instagram about it and people got
super upset with them.
You know,
that he talked about this as a peaceful
thing and that he has these animals that
he loves and cares for and you can see
pictures of him like touching them and
holding them and then later they're
packaged up as meat. And I'm like, but,
but you've, you saw just a steak,
you wouldn't have a problem with it.
Like if someone said, look, I cook the
steak, you'd get a lot of people are like,
Ooh,
that looks good.
But if it's like I killed this
animal and now I'm going to cook it,
people are like,
you're a monster.
Everyone has to other than
getting hit by a car son.
And people have to put down their dogs and
their cats. Yeah. So maybe this is not,
and that lamb is being bred for that
purpose and it's being done painlessly.
That's the important thing.
And I'm sure that Lam had a good life
and it wasn't a factory crowded shoulder
to shoulder existence is torture
situation. Yeah, I'm sure.
But it's a very quick life, you know.
And Lamb is a baby lambs, a baby.
She nature's about us eating babies.
Yeah, I have no, I haven't had mutton.
I haven't had like a sheep, sheep,
you know, that's such a British thing.
And it's always like in these old
storybooks you read. But like now,
I don't think he'd get become
adult unless they're for,
they're for or their hair.
Well, I, I've had wild sheep.
My Friend Remy, Remy Warren,
he gave me some, um,
some, um, wild sheep. Um,
backstrap it was very good. Some wild
sheep that he killed. I'm going to,
while I'm here, I'm big on dry.
Um, hagfish have you ever had that?
That's that weird fucking slimy
thing at the bottom. The ocean.
How do they cook that? I,
it's Korean barbecue. There's
one place here that has it.
I like, oh, super legit Korean barbecue.
Yeah. They're cooking. Hagfish yeah.
While I'm cooking it, I guess
technically. What does it taste like?
Like I haven't tried it yet. I can't wait.
What's the reports? Uh, not that good.
I'm not surprised to like
sign me up. Well, I like,
since I have a zoology
background, I like, I'm like Noah,
but I want to eat at two of every
animal, you know? Have you had yet? I
have it. It's tasteless. It's
weird plastic. Yeah. It's
the sauce that hasn't chest.
Yeah.
Strange.
I ate at a restaurant that's in the win.
Yeah.
It's in the win and it's the only five
star Chinese restaurant in the country or
in North America. It's insanely
good. Like you realize like wow,
it's true. Like you don't see
a whole lot of gourmet, right?
Like super high end Chinese restaurants.
What? Did you have anything weird there?
Yeah, I had that. I had jellyfish
cucumber had no, I didn't have that.
I had abalone. That was
really, I was not that.
A lot of times it's like credit cards.
Abalone. Yeah. It wasn't the taste. Yeah.
I've had abalone before and I liked it.
I liked it. I don't, I don't love it.
It's expensive too.
What do you got Jamie?
So from a couple of articles I just
found the, the issue seems to be,
and pea protein, which is what is
used to make these burgers and dark.
What I've found about what you were
saying is the impossible Burger actually
tested 11 times higher when tested for
glyphosate than the beyond Meat Burger,
which is, there's two different
versions of what's in very light weight.
I eat pea protein, protein chips
every day. Is that a problem?
So there's an article that you're getting
some glyphosates. What does that mean?
Bloomberg not good says pea protein could
have its own concerns. Detox project,
a research organization looking into
pesticides of glyphosate has been looking
into it for every year. It says
that there is an issue, there's hot,
we can hardly find a
clean protein anywhere.
The results like those for other products
tested for the popular pesticides
aren't pretty.
It's a very,
we can hardly find the clean
pea protein source anywhere.
Jesus Christ's all got glyphosate.
There's,
but I still don't know what
glyphosate does to Kate glyphosate.
This was the idea.
Okay,
and please Google this
because the argument was
glyphosate is great because it
just kills the weeds and bacteria
and it doesn't kill people.
You actually drink it with a problem
they're saying is, no, no, no.
You have bacteria in your body,
so if you're taking in glyphosate,
you're killing the bacteria in your body.
It might not kill you,
but it's not good for you and
it fucks up your system. Okay.
This is the argument, I guess,
that they use to present in court.
They must have used this to, to get the
jury to award them $2 billion in damage.
Cancer. Yeah. Yeah. That's
not a Monsanto parent company.
Bayer fee faces thousands of roundup
cancer cases after $2 billion verdict.
13,000 cases right now. Yeah. Listen
man, this thing, I don't know.
See there's this, this is what the
problem, first of all, I'm a moron.
I don't know anything about any of the
science behind this. When I read this,
I see two different camps.
Just like so many other things.
I see people saying there's no evidence.
This is just, they're all hysteria.
But is that the people
that work for Bayer,
is that like their PR firm that's
putting this out there to try to like
alleviate people's concerns and
stopped some lawsuits in their tracks?
They try and do influence public opinion
on this or is there real that shows
that this stuff is very bad for you,
but there's definitely a bunch of people
online that are telling you that it's
horrible for you here,
exposure to glyphosate based herbicides
in a risk for non Hodgkin Lymphoma,
a Meta analysis and supporting evidence.
I don't want to switch up my pea protein.
[inaudible] good bro.
[inaudible] hemp protein.
Good. That should get tested
too then. What am I saying?
Just start eating steak. I
can't, it's hard for me to
eat much. What's the problem,
bro?
That's
ever happened?
Do you know who David Frank is?
Is that his name? Hold on, I'll send it
to you. Jamie is a fucking hilarious guy.
Who is, uh, this, uh, big, uh, steroid it
up bodybuilder. Dude. That's also very,
very funny. Okay. And uh, see the one
does the bro science videos. He's very,
he's bro life talking like this.
Let me, let me find his, uh,
seeking to get me all swole. I sent
it to these guys to, uh, the, my,
um,
I have a fight companion
Twitter feed that's going,
I'm not Twitter feed. Um,
text message group text.
Here it is. Robert
Frank. Hold on a second.
Abortion. Yeah, it's here. I'm going
to send this to you. Hang on a second.
Do you know what it is, Jamie?
Robert Frank. Six one five private.
It is, yeah. Oh No. Oh, so he's got
a sign up. Got million followers,
but like I don't follow him.
Oh,
it's one of them deals because he says
a lot of crazy shit. All right, so, um,
how long does it take to be
the length? Fabulous yet. Okay.
Hold on a second.
I'm going to text it to you right now.
How long does it usually
take for what those people,
they have to be either one of those
dorks and sit in front of the computer or
someone's doing it for, yeah.
Yeah. He must've allowed me in.
All right. I'm sending it
to you right now. Bam. Okay.
It went through.
Do you go through
anyway? It's hilarious
in post. It's hilarious.
This is no taking anything out.
No need to.
No need to try and make it smoother.
It's hard to put the calories
down though, is my point. No,
it's not open your mouth chew
swallow what? Your baby, your,
your grandfather would have died
for a steak like this. Jesus Christ.
Listen to yourself.
You saying all this shit that you would
get mad at people if they were saying
about any other subject. It's hard. It's
hard to eat all that food. It's hard.
It's hard to get by in this
world. It's hard. It's hard.
It's hard to get up every morning.
It's hard. I work hard. I work hard.
How fucking hard is the deed steak? Look
at me, Bro. Just eat it. Cook it. Eat it.
Put some salt on it.
D licious maybe like some steak sauce.
Do whatever you gotta do to get
that steak down your stomach, sir.
Get some grass fed. Grass
Fed, grass fed, grass raised.
It's got a darker, richer taste. It
seems like a lot of work. Grass Fed. No,
just cooking steaks all the time. Slot
that hard. You learn how to do it.
It's easy. Is it? Get yourself a nice
grill. All right. I'm in Brooklyn though.
You're in Brooklyn. You got a yard?
No, no. Oh, hang on Brooklyn. Come on.
Get a cast iron skillet. I can
get one. That's all I need.
It's not going to think of my house.
Yeah, it'll stick up your house. Okay,
meg steak. Yeah, go man's house.
Smell good. People will be like,
tease that Michael's live
in. Good. He's got the steak.
Life could be knocking on doors that
butcher box bros at grass fed and legal.
Oh look, just cut it for me. Let me see
what you got. You got a medium rare.
Oh yeah. Kosher salt. Yeah. Crushed. Well,
I got to be kosher so it's a thicker,
so that's why I use,
I like the pyramid salt. What's that?
It's shaped like a pyramid that crystals.
Yeah, they do it a certain
way. No, it's crunchier.
If you want to cook a steak like a man
correctly, you need to kosher salt. Okay.
How many, how much grams of protein
or a steak? A lot. So I need to know,
shut your fucking mouth.
I followed my macros
every day. Oh, do you?
Are you really getting serious about that?
I've always been cause I
have an eating disorders,
so this is a way to put that in a
good direction. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Um,
you'd have to look, I mean it's,
it's certainly more for wild game,
which is mostly what I eat than it
is for a store bought meat. Okay.
But store bought meat,
I would,
I would guarantee you that there's
more nutrients in grass fed meat.
I don't know if there's more protein.
That doesn't seem to make sense.
But if you look at like it could be more
protein because they might be less fat
or whatever, but more
fat. Yes, that's true too.
Of course it would be more
protein if it was leaner. Yeah.
For the same amount of ounces.
Yeah. But there's also, um,
a bunch of other shit am tour
and essential fatty acids
that exist and grass fed
meat. It's all good. It's
all good stuff. Okay,
let's get some state stop with the pea
protein, bro. Okay. Sorry. Approach.
I'm not eating your people. It might
be fucking you up, man. I wonder,
I wonder how many people
are getting fired.
What are the dangers of
consuming glyphosate other
than non Hodgkin's lymphoma?
Maybe this is what you're seeing over
and over and people kill my gains.
There was my date. I don't think
pea protein is helping your gains.
There's something about knowing that
you're getting all your protein from peas,
all of it.
Some of it just makes you 60 grams a day.
What do you got to an endocrine
disruptor. Oh, that's no joke.
That's what glyphosate, oh, fuck.
Liver disease. Birth defects,
reproductive problems and animals.
Oh Christ.
What does this from a just typed
in dangerous of glyphosate.
I don't want to get you,
I don't want to get a birth defect.
I don't know what that is.
Pull up whatever you RTKL is fine.
It might be horseshit. We
should otherwise. Dot Org.
You ask us right to know,
right? To know that doesn't,
that doesn't mean anything. Like what
does it, what does that based on Virginia,
look at that top news on the right
trial for Monsanto. Hometown.
It's all Monsanto.
Everything's Monsanto.
This is another genomist just news stories
from today. They're all over the news.
Right? But you gotta be carry this.
This is not real story though.
Look at all the top news is all my
contact. I bet you it's just some,
it should have, uh, some dude,
GMOs are low. What is it?
Or Litigation. Oh, they're
litigating. This is from the
lawyers. Mm. Could be. Yes.
Pushing for Truth and transparency. This
is the lawyers. Yeah, the food system.
This is looks,
and if there are $2 billion rulings,
you can bet your sweet ass shit.
People that are swarming on this subject,
what would it be?
A better source of information? I
don't know, man. It's a good question.
What do we got here, Alex? Let's
call Alex Salmond. Kill. No, he,
I dunno if he's up on food stuff.
He knew about the plastic
wrap that gives you racist.
You're kind of estrogen ones that makes
the frogs get scientific American.
Yeah. Okay. That's good.
That's good. That's good.
2009 weed whacking herbicides.
It's deadly to human cells. Used in
gardens, farms in parks around the world.
The weed killer roundup
contains an ingredient that
can suffocate human cells in
a laboratory. Researchers say, yeah,
so we'll kill my gains if it's suffocating
myself. Fuck that. Whatever that is.
Whatever, whatever has that
on it. Fuck that stuff. Okay.
I'm going to go more weight than
carnivore. Die. That's your move. Okay.
And I'd like Jordan Peterson. Jordan on
cardboard. Yes. Okay. Over a year. Huh?
It's helped him tremendously.
How so? Well, first of all,
and intellectually he says it's really
alleviated a lot of his autoimmune issues
that he thinks we're slowing him down
and wearing him out and making him tired
and he has more energy for things.
He says he's at his peak
intellectually and he credits that.
A lot of that through this diet. He's
lost 50 pounds. All he eats is meat.
When I'm saying all eats is meat, I
mean that's it. What about drinks?
I brought stuff. There is none.
He doesn't have any of that.
He drinks water and he eats meat. And for
the below you all what? I've heard this,
I heard that. Okay. You know what
else I heard? I heard that uh,
the food pyramid was all green at the
bottom and that's not the case anymore,
right?
There's a lot of shit.
And I'm not saying this is for everybody
because it's not for everybody.
It's not even good for everybody.
There's a lot of people,
if they ate meat every day, all
day, probably be terrible for them.
But for some people in PR,
it seems that particularly people with
autoimmune disorders, they achieve some,
at least anecdotally, some
really positive results. Um,
Jordan Peterson has
gone as far as to take,
I think he took three blood tests when
he had a one year in for insurance
purposes and which things
showed because you know,
obviously you're going to ensure a guy
who's 55 years old just eat steak all the
time. Like, Oh my God, this guy's
going to die. No, everything's fine.
Everything's healthy. Um, no
coronary artery disease, no plaque,
no cholesterol levels are all fine.
Everything's fine.
This sounds like it would be exorbitant
though too. Financially. Yeah.
I'm maybe not the cheapest
way to eat the world. I mean,
you can get Costco steaks. You get, uh,
some supermarkets have cheaper cuts.
I'd really depends on what know.
You could also eat just ground beef
that's not as bad. You don't eat as much.
And that's one of the
reasons why when you're on a,
what they call an elimination diet,
one of the, one of the coolest,
you eliminate base basically everything
that might be fucking with you except
the one thing that you can consume easily.
And this is one of the things that
they're calling the carnivore diet
elimination and elimination diet. Um, when
you do, do you wind up eating less food,
which is one of the reasons why these
people just eat steak and wind up losing
weight. They don't, they don't take in
any car. Let's they're off basically.
It also kind of Atkins if they're
not taking a car, sort of,
but there's a thing called
glucogenesis and uh,
like not necessarily sort
of Atkins but sort of Quito,
but it's more Atkins than Kido and that,
that Atkins Diet works.
You stick to it,
it does work.
And when you stepped away and when
your piece starts to smell, it's great.
That's when you know the party started.
You're in Quito. Genesis. Great. Yeah,
ptosis, ptosis. And when
you're in Ketosis, man,
you really do have energy throughout
the day because your body is not craving
carbohydrates. You don't have this
up and down blood sugar crash.
The thing about the carnivore diet
is it's not even ketogenic really.
I mean you're in Ketosis sometimes,
but you're not eating that much fat.
You're just eating a lot of
meat and a lot of it with fat.
Some of it without fat. That's not
ketosis is look, when you have no carbs,
it's not a function. No. Here's why,
because when your body eats a lot of steak
and you don't have any carbohydrates,
you, your body does something
called glucogenesis where
it'll convert stake into
glucose so it actually convert protein
into glucose and it actually knock you
out of Ketosis. If you take in too
much protein and not enough fat,
it's got a portion.
Ketosis is I think somewhere
in the 80% range. If you you,
you should be consuming like
80% of your calories from fats.
He'd be kind of amazed and actually
can fuck with some people's gains.
They don't think they're getting enough
protein because they're getting a lot of
fat in a smaller amount of protein,
like less grams of protein might not
be ideal in terms of like a physical
performance for athletes they think.
But when you,
when you do do that and you just eat
steak, your body says, all right,
this asshole doesn't want to eat apples.
You know,
we have to figure out how to get our,
our carbs and we have to get it
figured out how to get our sugar.
So we're just going to get it through
the steak, Huh? Yeah. It's a weird thing.
It's like people,
some people are unaware of that,
but your body literally produces it turns
protein into like a glucose substitute
or glucose actual glue. It's
Glucogenesis. Hmm. Yeah, you can do it.
I've done it for several days. I've
never done it for a long periods of time,
but I was, I wanted to try it. Um,
when they're there were doing national
carnivore monthlies knuckleheads.
This people are so into it. Carnivore
diet is a lot like the Vegan diet is,
they can't shut the fuck up about being
a carnival or my buddy Michael Goldstein,
who is the first percentage of know
who's a bitcoin is that bitcoin, bitcoin,
bitcoin. Same thing with
cognitive, all the cargo,
cargo, cargo or like, all right.
So I tried it for
a couple of weeks.
I think I went from like close to two
weeks and after awhile I was like,
Jesus Christ 20 eat regular foods.
I'm not being, I'm not joking.
I would think it'd be a
problem with getting it stuck
in your teeth all the time.
No, you just brushed your teeth. What do
you disgusting. What's wrong with you?
You don't have a toothpick at home.
Excuse me.
I have every flavor of Marvis on
my shelf right now. Marvis oh,
interesting.
Now who doesn't know about tooth care?
What's Marvis is the like
Italian toothpaste, Brad.
And it looks really cool.
Although the, uh, this flavors and
subpar, the point is brushing your teeth,
not going to get, not stuck
in between your teeth. That's
not gonna help. Flossing.
Yeah. Flow. You got to be
up to flossing all the time
or just bite off bigger chunks like a
man. Just swallow it. I, oh, can I tell,
can I tell you a story about this?
This just happened to me. Yes.
And this is when I realized that, uh,
most people, there's no mind there.
I am at a buffet. I'm eating
steak. I was eating steak.
Congratulations. I, it's gets stuck
in my throat. I'm like, all right,
it's just too big a piece. I'll just
wash it down. It's not going anywhere.
And I realize I'm choking.
And it was a very scary situation in the
sense that mentally I knew there is a
percent chance that I'm going to die. Did
you try to throw up, hold on, hold on.
Let me tell the story. Joe Rogan. So
I'm sitting there, I'm like, Holy Shit,
I'm choking. And I'm like, all
right. I was calm, but I'm like,
it's your life is currently in danger.
And there's a co three
people at the next table, um,
to got to two women in their
50s and got in their sixties.
I go up to them and I'm like,
I know what to do cause I was at school
and I go to them and I go, I'm choking.
And I did the hand motion and I
make eye contact with each of them.
No, no effect on their face. And I'm like,
at the very least you have a crazy person
coming up to your table doing a neck
motion. Are you in New York? Yeah, that's
a problem. I Ip, we're desensitized.
Did this to myself and it's shot out.
And then I go, how'd you do it yourself?
Show me how I just did this.
And I saw Heimlich, like,
I don't know if it was
the call for whatever it,
it popped out and all the liquid to
after it. And I go to them, I go,
I was just choking. And they're like, oh
well you should show your food better.
I'm like, someone was just, Chuck
said that to you one the ladies,
she get that lady's name,
she doesn't happen to you because
there's not a human being there.
There's no mind. And I'm like, Holy Shit,
if I saw this happen and I didn't help,
I would be like, oh my God, you just, oh.
I'm like, Holy Shit. Are you okay? It
was like, oh, she should your food.
You're not a soul.
How old was this lady in her fifties
somebody probably just true. Your bad man.
Not Bad enough. Bad
relationships. It was scary.
The reaction was scarier than the
choking. Yeah, I would imagine. Well,
I think that's a really common thing
with big cities that that sort of,
there's a diffusion of responsibility,
but there's so many people,
there's so many.
You don't feel responsible for this
guy with his hands on his neck saying,
I'm coughing like somebody else.
Go Tech, somebody handle this.
I've got to go to work.
I would be fine
if they had shrugged and then
like, yeah, whatever. In a sense,
but there was no reaction.
She's probably so jaded.
So whoever you are, lady, I hope
that things happen to you. Fuck you.
I hope you go back in time and you have
a better daddy and a better mommy and
better friends. Yeah. And he grew up
to be a nice person and I, and yeah,
in her fifties maybe she could be a
yoga teacher in her mind and be like,
I saved someone's life today.
I can go on to heaven. Yeah.
Maybe she thought you were nuts and you're
just trolling her, but if I was nuts,
you would think they'd pull
back and be like, Holy Shit,
there's a crazy person or a table. Maybe
it's because of your troll. Likewise.
[inaudible] lesson. The universe has sent
your way. You're the boy who cried wolf.
No, no, no, no, no.
The lesson is you're invincible and
nothing bad will ever happen now. Oh,
because you survived. I survived. Oh,
do you know how to do that to someone
else though? If someone was choking,
do you know to give a high like, I think
I do it. We all think we do. Right.
That's the thing, but it's like
you have to get it right here,
like right where the rib cage,
the stardom and you push up.
I think people get the ribs broken
all the time that they're supposed to.
You're supposed to do as hard as you
can. Oh, you don't want that? Well,
the alternative, the ads are Matthew's
doing that to you. Sorry. As you can.
That would be very painful.
It would just be like an old
chicken. Yeah, no pea protein.
Then you get in trouble
for helping and hurting.
Of course you can 100%
of chorus or something.
You can get in trouble
for shooting a burglar.
Especially if you're a strong person.
Like if you're like a that Robert Frank,
are they approved you yet? No, no,
no. I'll check Twitter account.
I couldn't tell what the video was. You
might have it on Twitter. Maybe it's a,
yeah, I bet he does write well,
but isn't he like, um, he's um,
I don't know what the topic was
because he had a couple of videos up,
but it could have been, this is what
it looks like. I'll show it. Oh,
it's for some reason now Instagram wants
to send me Twitter wants to send me to,
um,
the Instagram from the web
and not from what happens.
And you're in an apple.
One of the do that should've been
in a wet mess it up on an android.
Why does it do that? But does Andrew
would work better for that for today?
For the purpose of it, for the purpose
of the show but doesn't, doesn't know.
The thing about Google though is the goop.
I have android to look up an
android phone as well, but don't,
doesn't Google a collect way more data
than apple does? I think they, uh, yeah,
it's my understanding there's this
gathering data and selling it.
Where's apple is kind of trying
to avoid that. I want to support,
apple did a great,
great thing where they had that set up
where they can't even break into their
phone if they want it to. And define law
enforcement. That was really wonderful.
Not just that, but your
information, right terms,
you relocation information and where
you're going and what you're doing.
Like Google, every time you're getting
online, they're just trying to do like,
where are you at? What do
you want, what do you need?
There's a great documentary
called the creepy line. Um,
and they talk about like,
let's suppose face on Facebook and I want
to influence elections, right? What if,
if I have an ad that says get out and
vote, it's going to crush people vote.
What if I've ran that ad on Donald Trump
fans? People who like Donald Trump,
right?
Don't run on Hillary fans.
That would sway the election
and no one would know. Mm.
So what they do with this information
is very quiet and there's not that much
transparency. And it can really
lead to, especially with the sheer,
with foreign countries, how with
China, how they're like, you know,
being perfectly happy to kind
of sensor stuff. This is,
these are things that need to be asked.
Yeah.
I was talking to a wound
was as an executive and her
position was that if they
didn't do at Google is
going to copy it anyway.
So might as well just let Google sensor
and this way Google won't invent their
own Google. Sure. And just copy
all the codes and steal the code.
And that's a fair response.
But these are things that people I think
should think more about. Yeah. Well,
especially with something like China
where the government and the industry are
all tied in.
Right.
This is why I was really weirded out by
this Walway thing today when it came to
Google and Google because you want to say,
well,
if Google's doing this, clearly
there must be a real reason for it.
But then you know about the Google
memo and James Demore and you're like,
oh yeah, whoa, whoa, whoa. Why Nay?
Oh yeah. Cause when you've done that,
I've got to go, okay. The guy just
provided scientific information,
didn't say anything sexist. You're just
talking about the facts of studies. Right.
And you,
you fired them for what you called like
was it reinforcing sexist stereotypes?
And it wasn't the case at all.
It's not what he did.
But so many people were complaining about
his report on the data that they were
asking about.
Well also saying that he doesn't know
math and statistics when that was,
this isn't even MIT to cre. Yeah, well
he's a, he's a coder. Yeah. So it's,
it's what happens is when you
have this fundamental is faith.
You start with the conclusion and you
reason your way backward and if you're
contradicting my conclusion,
you're not only wrong,
you're a liar and a sinner and have to
be driven from the face of the earth.
Well that's why I would ordinarily
defer to them. I'm like, wow,
this must be pretty serious.
If Google is looking to take Gmail off
of the new Walway phones and not update
the operating system, but then I
go, well no, that's on this story.
What's going on at all?
Yeah. I don't know.
We don't know what's going
on and we might never know.
That is a problem when you
do one thing like that,
like there's giant consequences for
what they probably thought it was a PR
disaster. Probably have to get rid of
this change to more guy. Let's just do it,
will justify it and I think the culture
of the company probably support it.
It's probably very leftist mandates.
It didn't support it and demand that it
was my understanding the company. Yeah.
Even though it does logically and did the
rest of that was really interesting to
just see outside of the bubble where the
rest of the world that people actually
read his memo and looked
at it and we're like, okay,
what is wrong with what he's saying?
He's not saying anything bad about women.
He's in fact he had a page and a half
talking about strategies to get women more
interested in tech. He was just
relaying the information as a stance
in terms of the studies that have
been done that show what women tend to
gravitate towards,
what men tend to gravitate towards.
These aren't sexist studies.
These are studies where they're just
trying to figure out why do more women go
into healthcare? Why do, is it
opportunity? Is it designed like is it,
is it just natural cultural?
It's cultural.
I mean sure there's a lot of
things and so data is not sexist.
This guy was just talking about data and
then when you looked at his own ideas,
those rent sexists either he was just
talking about strategies that women might
disagree with you.
They will say data is sexist because
it has conclusions that contradict what
they air quotes know to be true. So
therefore, if the data contradicts this,
the data is sexist.
That's so crazy that that's the left.
The left used to be science driven and
now the logical ones that are left has,
this is one of the big myths,
and I talk about this in the book they
have from Woodrow Wilson on have this
evangelical fundamentalist faiths,
a segment of the left.
There's many people on the left who are
very science driven, who are like, look,
these are the facts.
Let's work on that.
But there's a big segment of them
which are very prevalent where they're
basically like jihadis and you
have this on the right as well,
where it's just like,
these are my conclusions and we're
going to force everyone to fit said
conclusions.
Mm.
So you think that even like
when you go back to, um,
what was that fucking,
there was the terrorist organization
that Obama's professor was involved in.
The weatherman. The weatherman. Yeah.
Like that. You go back to that similar,
almost like an educated version of Antifa.
I'm going back to Woodrow Wilson. Yeah.
But I mean if you went belly, yeah. It's
real similar to what we were. Absolutely.
Yeah. Uh, and they, that's,
there's a book called days of rage and
it talks about how in the early seventies
there were bombs going off I
think every week in America.
And they weren't trying to kill
people. It was political. They,
they called him the bomb threat and be
like, look, we're going to set up a bomb.
But the point is they,
there are other Symbionese Liberation
Liberation Army that had patty Hearst,
a few of them. Yeah, the
weather underground. They
really, this was their thing.
And they blew up a townhouse
in New York City, you know,
killed a bunch of people and now
they're walking around and they're fine.
It's a fast and,
and it's all been swept under the rug.
Like people always think that no matter
what's happening now is like regardless
to like these like New York
Nazi types and the outright, oh,
this is the worst time ever.
It's like the Klan used to be like a major
part of both political parties. Like,
what are you talking about?
Things used to be re Woodrow Wilson is
playing birth of a nation at the White
House. Things were really,
really dark before. Um, and,
but people don't have the
historical context. No.
It's easy to not know
what happened before,
but just to think about what's going
on now and where you want things to go.
Yeah. So therefore it's really, really bad
and different. Must be the worst. Yeah.
There's a better,
there's a better way to live for sure.
But I think we went,
went into real problems when you
start telling people what they can
and can't do. Yeah. No matter
what it is, no matter what it is.
And you tell people that what they can
and can't do. You sort of reinforce,
I think one of the things that's
going on now, um, in terms of, uh,
like these abortion rulings.
Oh Gosh. Yeah. Yeah.
Which is very sketchy, very
scary. And the Alabama one,
which essentially just outlaws abortion,
they're making it where your punishment
for abortion is far greater punishment.
Then the punishment for raping someone
and causing them to get an abortion. So,
well, they don't punish the woman.
I thought the players, the doctor,
the law punishes the doctor.
Was that what it is? Yeah. Yeah.
I think doctor gets 99 years
or something like that.
It's the doctor who's being charged,
not the woman.
That's the question is in Georgia
and Alabama, maybe baby. Right.
But the question is why do you want this?
If you regard this mother
as a potential murderer,
do you really want her raising that kid?
Right.
Forced her to go ahead 99 years in jail.
Oh yeah. That they thought.
The other thing is that I
am very torn in this issue,
abortion on Twitter.
It's such a cesspool of people who don't
understand each other. One group saying,
oh, it's all about, uh, uh, you
want to control a woman's body.
And the other would be like, oh,
you want to murder babies? No, no.
They don't want them or to babies
and they don't care about the woman.
They care about what they
perceive to be the infant.
So I try to talk to both and
it's, it's just noise. Yeah.
These are rigid ideologies
and they're not persuasive.
If you tell someone who is pro choice
could wait otherwise be amenable to your
point of view. Well, you just want to
murder kids. It's like, well I don't,
so there's nothing to talk anymore.
Did you see that at state representative
that was walking around, um,
in front of a,
um,
a abortion clinic and was trying to get
the names of these kids that were there
that were oh yeah. He's still on Twitter.
Yeah. No consequences. That's crazy.
He was trying to docs kids.
He was asking for,
he was going to be offering
money bribing though. Yeah. $100.
$100 to get the names of whoever
these people are. It's insane.
Gets to this one boy. And he puts his
boy's face on Twitter. Just some meek,
shy Christian Rice,
a big guy.
He's big and aggressive and he's getting
in people's face with the camera. Right.
And then he's putting them online and
he's getting a lot of attention and fame
for it. And it's crazy. And
meanwhile, my buddy Mike,
he has a parody account of AOC. He
gets kicked off. That's crazy. Yeah.
And it says parody. Yeah. Why
can't you do that? I mean,
I don't think what he did was even
rough. It wasn't, it wasn't anything.
I don't really awful like I've read
some of the tweets. I was like,
they're just kind of funny. They're at,
they're a parody. What about site alive?
I think come on quickly.
Exactly what w Alec Baldwin does to the
president every fucking day on Saturday
night live every week. He's doing a
fucking Trump impression. All this. Well,
he should, that's their job.
Exactly. So it's, it's a
complete double standard. It's,
it's, and the other thing, I'll defend
jack in this regard we were talking
about earlier,
I'm sure the pressure he gets internally,
oh my God is off the charts and
he even said this explicitly goes,
they were all at, my whole company was
yelling at me to kick off Alex, you know,
for a long time. He refused to
do it for a while. Yeah. It's,
it's weird that they don't
see the consequences.
They don't understand that this is
going to go to a bad place, but this is,
they do see the positive consequences
where they're preaching to their own tribe
and basically the people who aren't
like us get to go out in the ghetto,
in the ghetto, in the wilderness. Well
I think human beings are way better at
expressing themselves today than they
ever have been in the past.
And I think one of the reasons why is
the free expression that we so enjoy and
that we have enjoyed.
You know,
like
if you, if you look at the,
the history of what you could,
the message you could get out just 40 or
50 years ago as opposed to what you can
get out today.
And then you looked at how culture has
radically evolved over the last 40 or 50
years versus where if everything was
stagnant like it was in 1950 we would,
we would think if you watch like 1950s
films are read books about the 1950s the
behavior that people got away with was,
it was way different than it is today.
Of course things are getting better.
But one of the reasons why these things
are getting better is because people can
see everything.
You can talk through all the details,
have you think you could
just cut off the ugly stuff,
cut off the Nazi stuff and cut off this
stuff and you're going to keep people
from getting recruited.
So you're going to kill this and
you're going to DIY platform this.
You're also gonna,
you're gonna enforce assholes to say
like there's a reason why their silencing
us. There's a reason why instead
of having people going, hey, no,
you guys are shit heads and
this is a stupid idea, right?
And you guys are all ignorant fools and
your perception of things is so often
we're going to explain to you while it's
off and we're going to all like work
this out together.
And when they say there's a secret elite
who's running this country and wants to
control your life, they made Jews
don't they? Shit Jig is up. They know,
shut it down this,
but this is their proof.
They can point to Twitter and
Facebook and they could also say, Hey,
they're picking off the same
exact people and every platform.
It's not a coincidence.
Yep.
Whereas David Duke is still on Twitter
isn't brilliant. Yeah, of course.
That's hilarious. Is it? No, but it's
telling no, it's not hilarious. Like, oh,
I know they got rid of Pharacom. They
didn't get rid of David Duke. Right,
right. Cause David Duke serves
a purpose. What purpose?
Because he's a good foil for the left
because when David Duke endorses a
Republican look, oh, the
Republicans are racist.
When David Duke Endorses Ilhan
Omar or Keith Ellison crickets,
though he'd be a good,
bad guy on payroll.
Like if I was the Democratic Party, I'd
say, look, Dave is the Jig is up. Okay,
everybody knows you're never
going to be president right now.
We're going to really run for office
or anywhere or legitimate blah.
She's not that good with that.
How about this, David? We'll
give you $400,000 a year.
All you have to do is every now
and then I'm going to call you up.
But I'm just saying, Dave, you
know, it'll be interesting.
It would be interesting if David Duke
endorsed this asshole and then David Duke
just starts talking about this person
being a fine American and a white
nationalists and all these different,
just make up a bunch of quotes and
have David Duke put it up there.
A lot of people when that
have a shake that off.
A lot of people think he's controlling
like not him specifically and trawl
oppositions controlF is
this. Oh, that's my favorite.
Right. When someone's not bad,
they must be controlled opposition.
That is one of my favorites.
I love their CE dork theory.
That control up position is someone who
you don't like who hasn't been banned
yet. Yeah. Controlled
opposition. Is it useful? Idiot?
Yeah. Controlled opposition.
It's like when people get into these,
uh,
I've been accused of being a CIA plant.
Oh,
you probably are probably
one of these ace for anarchy.
You know the term cognizanti like
those in the know know. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a great term. And that's like,
that's perfect for this. It's like, oh,
useful idiot. All controlled
opposition. I'm in the know,
I'm one of the cognitive symptoms. You're
not sneak this by me. I understand,
but me, while sometimes they're right,
which is why it's really fucked up.
It's like sometimes there
is controlled opposition.
Sometimes there is sometimes just fake
websites could talk to somebody because
somebody wants, probably somebody wants
a win, a lawsuit. You know, look at this.
I'm dear,
dear,
let this case that you're working on
come and look at this website I've found,
but that's why killing babies.
That's why it's so important for
there to be venues for those people.
If someone is crazy or brilliant,
bright off, it looks the same. Right?
But how does a person know whether
or not that websites, right or well,
once we got to scientific American, we
all go, you're like, okay, this is legit.
This is legit claim. They're
basically talking about cells though.
They were talking about human cells.
Um,
I don't know any better way
drawing human cells. But here's,
here's a problem with that, with what
was going to say is at what scale?
Cause by the way,
they've shown that certain elements and
plants in laboratory environment will
destroy cells even like phytonutrients.
And there was some something, um, one
of the head guys for the carnivore diet,
uh,
Sean Baker posted on his Twitter
a while back showing that,
um, that you can make a lot of
weird arguments based on cells.
Like how things respond to cells doesn't
necessarily mean once it gets through
the organism. Yeah. They
only way, in my view,
and I'm not an expert on this,
is discourse and having a platform where
people can argue at each other and you
could stand by and watch an NC things
through. Otherwise if you're silencing,
it's, it's, it's a very, as
we talked before and I think
any right might've person.
I agree it's a very, very
slippery slope. I agree.
Did you see the Ben Shapiro
meltdown on the BBC? I did,
yeah. Yeah. That's a good example. That's
a good example because I don't look,
he didn't handle it well.
He knows he didn't handle it well
and I like them like them a lot.
I think he's a really nice guy.
I like talking to him.
I don't agree with him on many things,
but I really like him.
He's a really good guy and
if he's a very smart guy,
I think he's smart enough
to admit that he fucked up.
He went on Twitter and instantly I,
here's the thing,
I didn't mean making fun of him,
it's on my insta and people are white
knighting for him. And I'm like,
he owned that, he played it wrong, he's
fucked up. And he's like, yeah, I got God.
And that's to his credit.
Yeah.
And it highlights to me
more so than anything.
The problem with two things, one doing
remote show. Sure. Where you're from,
you're in Los Angeles,
they're in the UK where he was
talking to him like he wasn't there,
the British guy was because
he wasn't really there. Right.
And then the other part is that short
time format, you don't have enough time.
You have at a time to have a conversation
and just talk that Ben knows this then
is that a pro?
He knows what the BBC is too,
but he's also a pro at doing those things.
You just shout talking points at
each other and talk over each.
And Ben talks super fast because
when he talks to profess,
it's really hard to keep up with him
and he sounds smarter than you like he,
he's very smart and articulate and
he talks fast. I was like, whew.
It's hard to him. He rose to prominence
when he was on piers Morgan. Yeah.
Talking about guns.
If he thought that BBC interview was rude,
peers at one point just goes,
you're real stupid man, aren't you?
Like that's your line, Benton
storm off. He was just like, no,
I just think with a governor that
comes to your patients that it's very
important for the citizens had the, you
know, and he handled the good impression.
We go to the same shul,
he handled it amazingly.
So for him as he admitted for him to
lose his shit and also to be like,
I'm popular and I've never heard of
you just because you've never heard of
someone. And I'm sure he would admit
this is of no relevance to their, uh,
the validity of what they're doing.
Yeah.
That's why I was shocked when I went to
Jojo Siwa last night and it was sold out.
I don't know the phone. I literally
didn't know she was until a week ago.
A lot of people know her.
I'm the Seg bore so than Ben Shapiro.
I'm the second most famous Joe
here. What the fuck? Athens
and she's 16 I was like, Ben Shapiro
did a speech at the Microsoft Center.
I don't know how many tickets he sells if
he does speeches, but it's a hard sell.
7,000 people to hard.
So I don't think Ben Shapiro could still
sell thousand tickets. That's a lot.
Yeah, but that's basically you're
getting a two hour speech in one hour.
So that's, you know, I already
have the double the value. No,
but it's getting people out of their
house to pay money to come see or hear
people talk. Like most of these, like
when these guys are doing these talks,
unless it's Jordan. Jordan can kind
of do a football stadium right now,
but a lot of these guys are
doing like 2000 seaters.
This is 7,000 this is a big
jump. Okay. She was seven people.
I bet you he can fill it. Maybe. Maybe
it's possible. I don't know. I'm like,
I don't know if he's
doing live ones like that.
There's a lot of people
doing live shows now.
It's very interesting because they're
doing the whole time. You too.
Very old timey. Yeah, but it's also,
it's cool to see people that
are interested in intellectual
dis like Sam Harris,
some fantastic and I like some,
what is some of Sam's live ones too?
Because he's funny in them. Yeah.
Which she's, he gets a chance to
actually work to the crowd. You know,
I was talking to them about, I'm like
you have good timing. Yeah. Like a comic.
Like some of the stuff you say actually
makes me laugh when he does live ones as
opposed to he's very like rational and
somber when he's doing straight, you know,
just, just conversation.
Once you know, this is a
performance stayed with me. Like,
if you're in front of that audience and
the laugh is out of proportion because
there's so many of them and
just have that one liner,
it makes you want to be more on.
And it's like it's this meeting its
tail and it's really, really exciting.
It's also like a nod to the crowd that
you know that they're there and you're
trying to entertain them.
You appreciate them.
Like you say something
fun like you're doing it,
they know you're doing it because
they're there and it's funny, you know,
and let us Improv.
That's much more intimate.
You know when you've got that one liner
that you knew was in part of his speech,
it's great.
So they're doing their their way
where it's just conversations and it's
interesting cause they're getting
these giant crowds and you know, um,
they're also like do produced ones too.
Like radio lab does a produced live
one and it's really interesting.
They'll bring someone out and they'll
play sound clips and I dunno if they have
a video element of it. I
don't see, I think they do.
I think they have like visuals too,
but they're doing it all in these big
ass theaters and people love it and come
out to see it.
So for someone who listens to like radio
lab every week and they get a chance to
go and see it live, it's like,
wow, I can't believe it's
here as a part of my life.
And this is the danger of the help them
write their Twitter, Facebook stuff.
People are desperate and
excited to hear new ideas.
It's thought provoking people,
even if you disagree. Right.
Two of my favorite people,
like a lot of times if you hear them talk,
even if you don't care what they're
saying or disagree with them,
the energy and it's like this is
fascinating. It's such provoking for me.
It's just nothing's better.
I think there's something really cool
about people coming out to see these
really interesting discussions to look,
Jordan had a debate with this lava Jijak
yeah. Thank you for saying his name.
I think I pronounced it right.
Maybe you better you than me. Um,
about Marxism and it's sold out.
Yeah.
And then they had paper view.
People were buying.
This was like the dub WWII of our time.
It's like,
how are these two people
in a room together?
I want to see this and they actually want
to agreeing on quite a few things and
just, it was really an
interesting discussion. But
it's also interesting that,
that,
that Marxism is such a attractive
subject that they're willing to host this
giant event and pay to see
people debate this topic.
It's like this is this idea that you
could fill up a whole arena for an
intellectual discourse or a theater. I
mean, I don't know how big the place was.
And then you could also sell
paper view tickets for like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Who the hell is going to pay to hear that?
But that school get outta
here with that shit. It's not,
I wish school was like that or wish.
Right?
There's no better way to get kids
to hate learning than school.
Every kid is so excited about
the world, you know, uh,
go on us to go to the museum.
Well not every kid a lot read books.
Then you go to school and that all goes
away. You're a factory worker. So this,
anything that reinvigorate your show,
does this do reinvigorates your love of
learning and about how there's so much
interesting, crazy shit out
there. I who doesn't love that?
And that's the creative,
the jocks back in the day didn't have
that space and now thanks to you and
people like you, it's like, you know
what? I don't like reading books.
Readings enough for me.
I could sit here and listen for three
hours and I'm going to be a smarter person
than I was three hours ago and learned
stuff. Who Doesn't love history?
Even if you're the biggest meathead,
it's like this shit's interest.
Or like these crazy animals. He, the
biggest meat had to be like, oh shit,
that's cool to hear about this.
You know,
just there's a raft weevil which has a
hinge on its neck, but only the males.
And it's from Madagascar. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Don't thing it is a real thing.
And I was going to say this, like
it's fuel for your curiosity. Yeah.
And for your creativity,
it's going to give you ideas.
It's gonna like there's so much
fuel for creativity right now,
like more so than any other time.
There's so much information
and interesting shit you
can learn and do it easily.
Like you could just find a po, like, um,
I need to learn about economics and you
just find an economics podcast and start
playing it. And if the person's
good, you know, they're,
they're interesting to talk to
and they can do it in a fun way.
Like you are listening to Peter
Schiff guy, he knows his shit.
Like I've had them on a few times.
And the way he describes things,
it's like he's entertaining
as well as factual as well.
It's just a compelling charismatic person
while he's talking about these things,
he's getting fired up and you're like,
oh, okay. So that's how it works.
It's so much better than absorbing it.
And they're dry,
stale manner. And if, and then you go
from that like, Oh, let me tell you,
he mentioned this thing.
Let me learn about this. Oh,
there's a youtube video about this and
you go down this rabbit hole and it's
just like hours of
entertainment and you're a,
and you could have better
conversation with the people,
Hey, I learned about this,
this and that. I feel so far
behind kids these days. I'll go,
I mean an 18 year old today feel
like a 30 year old when I was a kid.
In what way? They're smarter. They
have more info. Yeah, more data.
They know it's horseshit and what's not.
When we were in our twenties we didn't
know what the fuck was real and what was
fake. There was no youtube,
there was no Google.
There was books and you didn't read
them all. I read them. I you might do,
I've read a lot of Joe. Yeah, I'm
older than you. Yeah. You had books
about like to find out whether or not
something's true. Right, like we do today.
You know what I'm saying?
Like when I was in my twenties like I
wasn't like researching subjects and I've
read a few books here and there,
but I wasn't researching things on
every single aspect of the world.
The way the,
the access to this information just so
radically different that you just have a
thing in your pocket that
answers your question.
What else is fascinating is Google and
other organizations have digitized entire
libraries. So many of these books that
are old are public domain and for free.
You can read this book from 1910 where
these ideas got started and instead of
hearing someone's interpretation of it,
now you can see where this idea developed
in how they looked at the world back
then. Now here's the real question.
Yeah. Is that acts? Absolutely.
We both agree incredibly
valuable resource.
Is that worth giving up the data?
Like maybe we should just accept the fact
that they gave us something to change
the worlds. Of course they got
super rich. Hey, mark Zuckerberg,
I know what you did. It's okay.
So can you take that data?
You're taking ticket pitch. Yeah. You
like the shaking urges person. Well,
you deserve it. You shouldn't,
you shouldn't just give
it away for free. Well,
I used the world in a better way.
Nah,
he should've take advantage of the fact
that you changed the world in a better
way to profit in some insane,
spectacular way. We generate
billions and billions of dollars.
The thing we don't know is how they are
generating that profit. That's the issue,
you know? So if they're doing it in a
certain way that we know about, all right,
if they don't,
this is where it gets tricky because
there's an element of fraud in it. Well,
I think they must be terrified,
but both Twitter and Facebook,
there must be terrified at their influence
of culture. The actual, yeah, of course.
There's no way they can't.
The responsibility must be insane.
Do you know how you know this?
Because a lot of people
who were Republicans during
the Gulf War, the Iraq war,
and now look back on it who
are beating the drum beats,
and I'm not gonna name names.
You watch interviews and they're like,
that shit was fucked up.
And when you look back and you
realize you had a part to play in this
unnecessary war,
and if you're someone who cares about
human beings as a Christian or whatever,
that will fuck you up for life because
it's like, I had a little part in this,
like when I do my work with North
Korea, right? If I help 10 people,
that's a huge fucking deal and I don't
take that shit lightly. I've had,
and here's the power of social media.
I've had people three or four tell me
I'm going through chemo and I read your
Twitter and it makes me laugh throughout
the day. That's fucking huge. Conversely,
if you're on the side of Hillary Clinton
and you realize that your website,
Mike would be contributing
to her, the mines. Oh yeah.
And all he had realized that
other countries might be
posting fake accounts that
are there. You know, they have these
groups, these discussion groups,
and they're based in Russia and they want
to talk about black lives matter. Yeah.
Or they want to talk about abortion
or they want to talk about southern
separatism,
her all kinds of,
you know that IRA
research group in Russia.
When you find out this is all happening
on your platform and that your platform,
yes.
Likely being used to manipulate
how the world is run,
how financial markets are
run international politics,
and you just wanted to help college kids
get laid. Yeah, yeah. Right, right, right,
right. And kind of Jack
the idea to, right.
What about the kids when they
were torturing that retarded
kid and was a Chicago and
there was streaming and our
Facebook, that's your site.
That's got to fuck with your head.
It's God. Well, there's been murdered,
I live streaming in New Zealand.
He was live streaming.
I mean, there's many, many
cases of horrible things
that had been put on there.
Isis beheadings and you know, I mean,
there's no way they can catch it all.
There's no way.
And we,
when you talk to Twitter or you talked
to Facebook or youtube or you'll,
they'll tell you the, just, just,
I want everyone to just think about
the idea that 7 billion people,
yeah, let's be real conservative.
Potentially 3 billion. Sure.
Just 3 billion.
3 billion people can all
send something at once.
Wow.
At the speed of light is of bits of
information headed towards youtube or
Twitter or Facebook. I,
they trying to catch it all.
Some of it's Nazis and some of it's frogs
and an Alex Jones, Ben, his name, blah,
blah, blah, blah. And they just,
everything's flying it out. I'm like, oh.
And then congress is like, Mr Zuckerberg,
you know what you're doing. It's like,
hold on, let me drink her water. Hold on.
Uh, Mr Senator, yes. We know
what we're doing. I think,
I think Mr. Senator, no, that isn't
no special or knows what he's doing.
Also, he's, he's not, he's not a
monk, right? He's not some scholar.
He's not a genius. He's not
enlightened. He's a guy. He's just like,
he's not a stupid guy. He's a
smart guy, but he's just a person.
Just a human and has an
insane connection and insane.
He's the CEO of one of the biggest groups
on the planet where people exchange
conversation,
which still hasn't verified
me on Instagram. By the way,
let it remind not because they're not
seeing how many followers you got.
Only 7,000 Instagram.
That's my weakest one borough.
You touched the fuck up,
but uh,
but it's also like Lucy, Lucille ball
when she's working the chocolate factory,
right. The chocolates are coming out and
then they go faster and faster. Oh yeah.
There's a certain point where you,
you're not going to be able to process
this much information and scan it and any
filter, any filter, by its nature,
any coder will tell you is going to be
imperfect and it's going to weed out
people. It doesn't want to eat
out and and leave people in the,
you don't want to leave it like any
filters only as good as its creator.
That's what I wanted
people to kind of understand from Jack.
And he did a pretty good job of explaining
that and then saying that it just
shows you the problems with
trying to monitor these things,
right.
Scale.
But the thing I would say to Jack is one
work around if someone is a high enough
platform where they're contributing
like the, the laws against obscenity,
the ruling was if there's some cultural
benefit here, it's not regards of scene,
right?
That's a blue pool.
If someone is big enough in terms of
their part of the public conversation,
you should have a manual person, double
check or triple check. They're blocked.
You could give them a warning.
Explain why.
Because it's important for [inaudible].
Here's the question for what it does.
If there's gotta be rules,
but you are getting blocked.
If you're threatening violence
against someone like you,
if you're sending like Dick Pics to
report or you should be blocked. I mean,
and if you're, if you have,
uh, you're putting up people's
information, find doxing,
putting people's address out,
right?
When you go to your home telling people
you want to pay someone $100 to take the
photo [inaudible] photo and video of
someone who's not giving you permission,
you're uploading in an offering. This
is what that guy did is offering $100.
That's crazy. So with sunglasses,
that work. Yes. Kim, I'm not jack.
How could that work? I
don't know Jack get it. Um,
but he very easily that people like that.
You should tell them you could that way
you'd be banding if you're doxing people.
Yes, but someone is doing a parody. You,
it could be like, take this down for x,
Y and z reasons do.
The thing is,
I think they tried to make a
differentiation between doxing someone and
threatening to dock someone.
This is how the kept Kathy Griffin on,
right? Remember when she was
saying, I want names of his
kids. Yeah. For these kids.
You know, imagine if
they did and the, the,
the kids eventually all their information
did get wind up getting online.
But when you watch the full video
and you saw what actually happened,
you're like,
God damn.
Like you'd be able to have really
shifted the narrative gets,
I posted a picture of myself holding up
a bloody Clinton Hillary Clinton head
that I wouldn't be banned. Ooh, I'm not
going to find out, but that's a big deal.
And I didn't even don't,
she was obviously doing as a joke.
I didn't find it offensive.
I think it'd be funny if she was
wearing a hijab while she did the photo,
but the point of shit, no consequences
on Twitter. None. Um, yeah,
I think you would be banned. Yeah.
Almost positive. You'd be banned.
It's for whatever reason,
it's more disturbing. See a
guy holding a woman's head.
Sure. That's true. Um, in the,
see, even if it was Obama,
the idea is like Kathy Griffin probably
wouldn't be able to cut Trump's head off.
Like he kick her ass. He's a
big dude. If she, you know,
she came at him with the knife.
I mean she'd have to shoot
him and then cut his head off,
which I guess you could do. It's not as
long as she's got to use the palms. Oh,
the palm to the nose. Tom's at the nose,
nose bone in the brain. Would you do that?
I'm just trying to like
run the numbers in my head.
There's 126 million
daily users on Twitter.
How many people should they hire?
Remember when we were asking me.
I know that's like, I'm just remember.
I'm like, that's going back over my head.
Like how that cue, if someone
could get through a hundred a day,
if they could get through a hundred a
day and spending five minutes on each of
them, that's 500 minutes.
That's more than there.
That's [inaudible].
No way you're going to do,
I'm going to have to use the
reporting system is smart. Yes.
Like you're relying on the users to report
things that are initiative that smart,
but it falls victim to trolling because
then someone can just decide to attack
Jamie Vernon. Don't do it. Got
Charles at the worst. Yeah,
those. Fuck Oh that's you.
Oh my goodness.
That's the bad kind of trolling.
That's just being an asshole dude.
We
already did three hours. Oh, how
are they? How's that possible?
I'm just adorable and charming. I guess
that's something something happened.
I'll go with that. It's
good to answer is any, um,
your book is called the New Right.
We barely talked about it. Um, more,
more stuff for people to
read. Yeah. A journey to the,
how's the first 12 pages inside joke.
A journey to the fringe of American
politics, Michael Malice. And,
uh, thank you, brother. Thank you, man.
That was a pleasure, Jeff. Thank you.
Bye everybody.
That was [inaudible].
Mm.